the pre-game
[Applause]
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos guys
you already know if you've watched two
or more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef like
i'll fight you right
um it doesn't cost anything to subscribe
so really hit that subscribe
button on top of that our sponsor today
is cooking with chris chris offers
completely customizable meal plans so
what you do is you give him the foods
you already like eating and he makes a
custom-made meal plan for you and that's
another way that you can help support
the show
on top of that i'm also looking for
people to host
shows on the channel so if you're
interested in that send me an email at
justpearlythings gmail.com and tell me
why you think you would be good for a
segment on the show
and don't forget to turn on your
notifications as well that way you're
gonna be notified every time i'm live
which is every wednesday thursday and
saturday at 9 30 pm um also let me know
as you guys know sometimes we have audio
issues so let me know in the chat how
the audio is
okay
let's go around and everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and where you are from
uh my name is eileen i am 24 from san
francisco california
uh my
situation is still
situation okay
i guess you would say take it
okay
okay hey um d um catchment 1833
um
i'm 37 so i'm [ __ ] old
and single
um davides i'm 22. i'm currently single
and from lithuania
hi i'm tiana i'm 20 and i'm from the uk
and i'm single
if you need to know
i'm a south london boy sorry
i'm a safe london boyfriend
okay so today's topic
is what are gender roles in
relationships in 2022
um so as you know like it used to be
very traditional right like it used to
be very much like the women stayed home
the men were more providers
um but as like more women entered the
workforce like things changed the
development of birth control also
changed a lot of things
so um i'd like to go around and everyone
say
what
do you believe do you believe there
should be gender roles in 2022
in relationships could someone else go
first um i don't mind going first i
think
that it i think a lot of it depends on
um
who the main bread owner is in the
relationship
and how much
that person earns as well mm-hmm if
you're both struggling if you're both
sort of average average earnings they've
got to split things up make things work
between two of you but if one of you is
like i don't know a millionaire mm-hmm
no one's not yeah you know no matter
what that one earns the one that's not a
millionaire earns doesn't really matter
it's in the relationship so then
and i always also believe that whoever
is the main breadwinner has the sort of
um
they sort of dominate they they lead the
relationship mm-hmm so the other one or
whatever it is whether it's a man or
woman has to sort of
kind of fall in line too so you think
whoever makes more should like submit to
the other basically like this oh yeah
yeah sorry sorry yes yes yes
and that's where things can be
complicated because okay we've believed
that normally it's men that earn more
okay when a woman earns more and
normally
especially if you own significantly more
than her partner then you're gonna
probably find some issues in a
relationship long term okay
um i'd say yeah i'd say i agree with
that as well but um
in a scenario because obviously back
back then it was very much like the
woman is the you know stay-at-home wife
and then obviously it was a lot of
development with like the females right
and all that stuff and now it's like
men are generally
earned more
but now because obviously like you said
gender equality and stuff um women can
earn
just as much if not more so it does kind
of
like put like um
a stop to the kind of like men earning
more and so that stuff that's uh type of
thing
um
and yeah that's that's about it from
okay i feel like
you should do like whatever you're good
at so if someone's good at cooking they
should just do that instead of trying to
push the gender roles let's say
the woman should cook even though the
man is like a chef i just found that
kind of stuff
oh yeah
yeah do what you're good at in the
relationship and make balance try to
make balance
i like that part yeah i like i think i
agree with the you know usually i i mean
i guess it's not it's just how it goes
usually whoever earns more the other
person usually submits because
i would say like you just feel like that
person is just
not like
over you are like bigger than you but
it's just it's just how it is but i also
do like that you know whatever you're
good at in the relationship like you
know just do it like
you know maybe the woman doesn't know
how to do laundry and the man's like you
know that's his thing yeah maybe he
loves like folding clothes it's like the
thing that keeps him like at people i'm
sorry
being from the i'm i'm sorry being from
the male agenda
i don't know any man that would love
folding clothes i promise you that now
any man that does i'm sorry
[Laughter]
um okay so what do you think if they
make the same amount of money
i'd say there's like a 50 50 thing
okay um let's say like you know if there
is like a kid that's on the way maybe
and then i'm assuming like they would
like discuss who would be the one who's
like not like the main caretaker but the
one that like stays i'm take care of the
kid and then
and the other one's like working to earn
money
but i don't think that there is any like
man or woman that should just be like
submitting to doing that i think there
has to be a discussion between the two
okay
i think it depends your tax bracket okay
tax bracket yeah i think how much you're
earning yeah i think i think
both average earners if you both are not
earning 50 000 but yeah for example
that's not a great wage especially in
london it's just a struggling wage in
london
and you've got to do things together to
work out together but you're both going
to have to work full-time right
so that makes things a bit difficult to
say well you should all you you should
do this i should do this because you're
both doing full-time work
if you're earning i know 250 grand each
then things become a bit easier because
then you can hire people to do things
for you yeah you have to worry about
who's cooking because you can go out to
eat more often you can get someone to
cook for you mm-hmm you have to worry
about who's cleaning up because you can
get a
leading cleaning ticket so the gender
roles stop a certain salary
i think
i think the in general is
i don't
today's cycle don't it's difficult it's
very difficult to have specific roles
um what i would say is if one it is like
i said if you're both working
then
especially working full time i think the
role thing is a bit more tricky to work
out
um and
you guys both mentioned do you eat
bester yeah and we're apart now we're
both working and i'm a better cook then
cook yeah she has cooked so well
sometimes it's not like okay
talk to her
but um if one of you likes what is it
what are you working the other one isn't
yeah that's a completely different story
what if he's working and one's not then
what you're doing mm-hmm
right that's true you gotta put your you
pull your weight in another way what if
one's like just like naturally wealthy
like they've inherited their wealth and
doesn't need to work and one has to work
like should that person still work
full-time it's like one partner is like
just wealthy like from a wealthy family
doesn't actually need to go to work
because they have that wealth already
and then someone would should you make
your partner go to work but i think i
mean if they already have a wealth and
then like they're just like you know
staying at the house they might as well
do like the stuff like you know
otherwise what are you doing just
sitting on your ass yeah while the other
person is like working their ass off and
like you know by the time they get home
then they're tired as hell yeah but i
was going to say i was going to build on
the first point that you made in a can
in a case of like
when a man and a woman have like a baby
and then let's see they're like average
you know they make average wage more or
less the same it should be 50 50. but
then the woman at the end of the day
still kind of gets an advantage so it's
not exactly legal because at the end of
the day you can talk about it but the
man's still going to go to work while
the woman stays at home for those nine
months or however many ex-mon mom's that
day she can stay things like buddies in
uk it's like yeah i think
a yeah yeah about about a year right and
she stays at home and you know she takes
here
it can be split between whether you can
choose who takes a year off whether it's
a man or a woman oh really
but now but naturally it's always the
woman yeah because more often than not
the man earns more women so it makes
more sense for her to be and also i mean
women here you're going to want to bond
with your children what have you yeah
and
what would you say for like after like
you know the kids like a toddler and
like you know
you can sometimes
again especially in london sometimes
sometimes it doesn't even make sense for
her to go back to work because she
literally just paints going to work to
fund childcare
yeah the point of that it costs the same
childcare is so expensive
with your child when you're young rather
than having someone else look after them
when we go out to work to pay them
[Music]
no no but like we're winning in a
department of like when the day comes
when the little kid says first words
yeah and all and the mother was there
nurturing and she says that oh man do
you mind you must be human that cuts
that cuts deep like i just nurtured you
for like almost and you're telling me
yes no
so i have a question for the girls do
you guys like a guy that looks to you to
make decisions
i would say
like what do you mean like what kind of
decisions um just like if there's a big
decision you have to make in your
household and instead like he doesn't
like he looks to you to make it instead
of making it himself
um
it's an interesting scenario i don't
think i've been in that scenario before
i've never been on that scene
give us a give us an actual realistic
scenario that would happen um a
realistic scenario um you have to decide
what
where you're gonna move or what like
just a property or something yeah a
house you're going to buy that's a big
decision
i don't think i would mind it at all
honestly
but i mean i also like would like his
opinion i guess because i don't want to
like move us all in one place and then
have him resent me for doing that what
about what about like dates when he asks
you like to plan the date would you
i mean i don't mind that i love like
really
you don't like that no not at all i'm
like a foodie so i'm like i will huh
um
you know us guys like we're not really
that creative now 2020 it's more or less
like oh let's go get some food and watch
a movie that's us all i could go good
stop pause rewind it again i said i was
first date no no no like yeah i know
like thursday i know it's gotta be a
little bit of fun like go top most
people like top golf something i got
active right but for the most part it's
a dinner movie then in the movie
you gotta talk slower
the accent
i just like like the i'm so sorry
first and foremost you shouldn't be
taken to any you shouldn't be taking a
go to the movies on the day unless
you've been dating for a long long time
yeah because then you just sit there not
talking
he gets it he gets it
uh no don't do that um and as i was
saying to you it was a first date it was
a first date and a guy said to you hey
let's meet up
you choose you it's all in your hand so
you pick it yeah you check the time you
use a date you pay for it
okay i mean i respect that he's like
putting like the control in my hands but
i want the control but i find it more
attractive when he's taking the control
himself
so if he's like okay
oh let's go on a date i'll make a
reservation somewhere then i'm like oh
that's attractive because he's making
plans like i'm not pushing him to do
anything if he's putting the control in
my hand it sends a different message i
would say like like when they do plan it
out it makes it seem like they are
really interested in yes and they like
want it more you know because then
they're like okay let's do this isn't
this mess and they like have a mind
already like have a thing in their mind
like they're like thinking about what's
going to happen and with the equality of
dating in the way men approach like
dating equality and dating i don't think
there is because
men don't have that many options and we
all know like men will swipe right and
all women on tinder and then get a few
matches and it's kind of the opposite
for women
yeah like women don't have to swipe that
often but we'll get matches that kind of
thing and just the way that men approach
women and get dates i feel like because
it's like formulated in that way that
men's kind of approaching the woman the
man is approaching the woman that they
should kind of organize the day like it
doesn't make sense to change that
when it's out that way so sorry i'm
going to ask a question so sorry for you
go ahead
so the girls in the tunnel is this um
so
just a quick yes or no and a later
second question do you feel that there
should be i don't think we answer that
question so should there be gender roles
in their relationship yes or no
um i think some gender roles are good no
no yes or no yes or no just
how traditional gender roles should they
exist do i not get asked the question
yes
yes but not like everything you know
like not like the old traditional but i
would say like some of them still i
think there's a bit of flexibility
within the gender roles yeah but i do
think that there's a positive side to it
so what about equality then
because
and i want to pause before you answer i
want to i'm going to say something to
think about it okay equality says
everything's equal right
gender roles existed when things weren't
equal
yeah so i'll say to you two things
uh
are not they can't work together
you think they're not mutually exclusive
i don't think that's true anymore i do
think there's gender roles and equality
as you think you can just do
bring what you can bring to the table
and this other person brings what they
can bring to the table and you kind of
match that and you kind of
if i do the cooking you can do the
cleaning or that kind of thing where you
both work together as a team at the end
result is equality that you both feel
like everyone's committed to the
relationship so it's not that i'm doing
more tasks than you it's more like i'm
helping you you're helping me and you
feel like it's working so okay now would
you say like there are generals they're
just not as restricted as before then i
think there are gender roles and i don't
think there's a problem with that yeah
but i don't think they're more flexible
so you can choose who has the gender
roles yeah like who's going to be the
person in the house like the house man
or housewoman and then they'll have
their roles within that the roles of the
house person who's staying at home it's
not like just the woman or just the man
for example so where i kind of describe
that is this
you would expect
as women i am i'm going to make an
assumption from wrong but i i assume
that you'd expect that man pays you
especially the first couple of dates you
spend time with us um i mean not fully i
mean so like i just like went to paris
and i was like
oh like let me run it for a while i
guess so okay you're right he you went
out for dinner you planned it he made
you ask for you to plan it
and he expected you to pay for the
drinks and dinner whatever you did in
the first day
how would you have felt at the time
would you have seen him again
probably
that is not you're gonna date on a guy
you've met a guy online or wherever and
he stopped numbers you're talking for a
while he goes hey let's meet up he says
you plan it you put a date you put a
time you pay for it
how do you feel i
i wouldn't feel positive towards it
because what's the point of me like
dating i don't know like having someone
being in a relationship with someone
like you're supposed to benefit from
that and if i'm making my own
yeah
you're financially stable you've got a
job you've got everything you need in
life why do i need to pay for a date for
a man
but i mean okay but you because you said
that if he was to ask me on a date i
would say if you're asking me on a date
then you want to take me on one so you
should be paying you're taking the
initiative to want to take me exactly
yeah
when i promise you well i do when like
if they're dating somebody like oh let's
go out let's have a first date there's a
so a woman meets a guy in a bar chats
him out guts his number talks to him i
think this happens more than you think i
think women push like a kind of a
catalyst for most relationships like oh
like we should meet up they push things
in that direction men are sometimes a
bit slow it's like okay i directly want
to go on a date they might talk for ages
if a woman doesn't intervene but
regardless like that wasn't the point of
the thing it wasn't like do women ask
men are they it's the point was he pays
when
my opinion that the two things along
with this you can't have gender equality
but then expect traditional outcomes
we pay for the day yeah but i mean okay
but if women were supposed to like were
to ask you on the day
i said if women were to were to ask you
on a date
[Applause]
and then
i mean i don't think they would they
would pay for the date weren't they
this is like a cultural thing i think
it's more about like culture than to do
with like gender equality so sometimes
we have traditions i just caught trade
makes sense for western culture that's
kind of like the gentleman kind of
stereotype just doing that no you're
going that extra mile for me
i can't i'll say a gentleman couldn't
exist in today's society if you have
equality it wouldn't didn't you already
existed in a time when men
out earned women we weren't allowed to
work we had to do it right so there were
things that men had to do for women to
be chivalrous if you're all equal then
why am i cheating especially why would
you be more special it's called true
point equal
if we're equal
it's a grand gesture it's not going to
open a door for debbie
that's cool
to come up the car you can be a
gentleman to a man like there's no like
there's nothing
no
no
no it does not no no no listen listen
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no for you no no
no no no no
okay you've got two bags of shopping and
a guy opens the door for you like one of
the guys like what do you appreciate
about that i appreciate the chivalry i
want to know
this is where the difference is right
it's like look it's one thing you're
like cool i'm not saying like yeah if
i'm walking outside like my hands are
full yeah and someone opens the door
like a guy who was walking past the
opposite that's that's like helpful i
don't want to consider anything like
that but i wouldn't expect a man to be
like yeah
wait
open the door for me and be like yeah
sit down close the [ __ ] background
like where we go like no i would never
we're in the car and i come around open
a door for you to let you in the car
side not you're like a man invented the
revolving door what a man invented the
revolving door because he didn't want to
open doors for women maybe thank you
thank you
thank you
he took her personally
why did you think we were going to the
rolls-royce man it opens the door
closes
so
no he actually has a decent point
because a common complaint i hear from
matt is that women want equality but
only when it benefits us
and so this is kind of a situation where
like yeah we want the date
yeah we want to be courted yeah but
at that cost yeah but like isn't that
human nature to try and get as much as
you can for as little
effort as possible yeah
you work the best job or like
that earns the most money maybe not
because it's like
nourishing for your mind you just do
what you can do that gives you the best
reward and i think that comes for dating
and equality as well i think maybe
that's probably why women like it when
men paper dates because
so do you think men should put up with
that is the question i mean men have a
choice they can say no yeah they can say
i'm not paying them i'm asking do you
think they should
it's up to men to make that decision
yeah they do to be honest
like i've uh i've been on like
enough data like where yeah
no
wow
you know i've been i've been to you know
i've been seeing enough days right no no
i've been to enough days right where
like obviously
i've paid obviously you know but like
what's someone what girls like miss on
that is like we don't do it like okay
we're obviously gonna pay right but i
just like that's that's from that's me
anyways
um
but it's like we don't do it just
because of like you know we got we got a
day so that we want it because we took
the time of that day to meet you to talk
to you we show that we want you know i
mean that and then when life for example
when something goes wrong and then like
oh you take that first date or you get
the food you get wherever you get
everything paid for you're all happy and
stuff like that but then you ghost the
man that [ __ ] that's just what that's
that's not cool let me give you a sorry
can i give you a second
never think i got on that date but first
date
for a meal don't do it
never do it this is me man somebody you
know yeah that's cool about it where
wait where are you taking them to the
park
right i mean
you love it yeah that's that makes sense
no investment i'm a family
by human nature
it must be a law investment because you
don't know if you feel that good again
you don't like that is true i mean that
doesn't make sense that makes sense
you might put some more money into it
but first date how much money is too
much money to put into a first date
that's a good question
depends on how much you like the girl it
depends on how much interest you have in
the world yeah like what if you've been
talking on the phone no i'm like
so you can talk
you could be talking on the phone and
but i guess it depends on how you've met
but um you could find that
sometimes you might be in a bar or
something you see someone come out and
see the daytime full glare of the sun
and not darkness that's not who you
thought she was
i mean you met
um if you're on a date and you don't
like the guy would you like pay for half
the date because you know you're not
going to see him again because i feel
like if you know that something's not
going well like i would feel bad like
making the person pay for like a whole
day so always like try and pace like i
know that like okay that's what i'm like
here's my problem okay i got
yes
sometimes like i'd want to do that but
i'm really i feel awkward
because i feel like
like if he he's insisting to pay right i
don't want to be like oh no don't pay i
never want to see you again
no i know but a lot of guys won't let
you
so like i'll just pull out like my cash
and like yeah
i don't know i always offer to split it
regardless just because like i don't
know you never know like the other
person's financial issue
is true but i never really do that
actually i'm taking a date you've got
what's it gonna do yeah i don't normally
do that but i do seem like it's a nice
gesture to do because then you're really
considering the person and maybe
it was just like the equality of dating
like
women invest in as much as men are
investing because women don't as invest
as much as men on like a first date i
think it kind of equalizes that and
that's nice but i just i can't see
myself doing it i've seen i've seen a
lot of women like on por like on other
podcasts and stuff like that there was
one general where it's like
they just oh i wouldn't uh there was one
very big one i think we've talked about
this in one of the previous ones where
the guys like i would not buy this man a
present and then if he gets sick and
can't walk i have to get myself a new
man like wait what yeah so the girl
there was a girl on one of the podcasts
right she goes listen
he has me as the gift as a i would not
buy him a present because if me as a
president he has me for days for this
for this and then this guy asked him he
was like listen god forbid your man
got sick and can't work he goes i'd have
to i'd have to find myself a new man
like that mentality in women why was he
with her
no no he wasn't it was just a podcast
that you
okay guys i'm gonna pause for a second
and read some super chats
um guys thank you so much for the super
chats as you guys know i really want to
get multiple cameras up in here so you
can get like
closer angles of everybody and then like
zoom in when they talk that's the vision
okay i need to raise about like 500 more
dollars to get that so every super chat
what
dollars so i don't know what that is in
pounds but
that's about 450 right give or take 430.
no i think it's small pounds
less
because one one pound is like equal to
about like a dollar fifty
right now yeah
i don't know but i'm gonna read the
super chat so celine 499 as a believer i
think the only way traditionalism
traditionalism works is if it's the
foundation is on scripture where it has
checks and balances for both men and
women um akuma so coast films hi pearly
sorry i couldn't be on the show tonight
like i said to you before both men and
women need to focus on their
responsibilities uh gender roles uh were
easy to define stop stunting
um
eat godly well i guess i have no chance
with pearly um
mgtow by logic is it is it wrong for oh
i'm gonna read that one last because i
think that's a good question
um let me see if there's any others okay
okay
um mgtow by logic is it wrong to accept
a date from someone who you're not
romantically interested in why or why
not
i would say yes
what's the point of even going on there
because you're wasting your time
yeah i think you should define your
intentions when you go on a date i think
it should be clear between like the
tradition of the day it should yeah yeah
no i i agree so the question is have you
ever been on a date with a guy you've
never been interested not been
interested in like you had you don't you
were like i don't want to see him again
i don't know i'm not attracted to him i
feel like i'm gonna date him anyway i've
been on a date with a guy where i would
like wasn't sure because i feel like i
was talking about for me for girls i
think we have three categories
yes no maybe
that's no i swear
that's a good category yeah yeah so it's
like there's some guys it's like yes
no and then the maybe
but in the future
or maybe it's like i don't i don't know
if i could see him as a friend or
romantically like so i have to get to
know him better to see
yeah you see that maybe yeah yeah that
maybe is is what really gets to us
because because what most girls do
that i've got that i've been actually
calling is they keep you in a loop which
basically they keep you in a string like
so you're not you're not committing to
him fully but you're not actually
excluding him out of the picture this
man is obviously you know you're seeing
him on a regular basis and you know
you're talking and you're seeing where
things are going but then you don't want
to commit them fully and that just gets
unmanned into like one of those like
very
deep like but men do that too yeah but
also we're talking about first dates
only right now like after you've like
met them and then you know and yeah yeah
so like i feel like at a first like some
people you just don't know that well or
or there's a big butt where it's like i
like him there's like
but you know something and so you're
trying to decide if you can get over the
butt yeah yeah
what what would it be a butt that you'd
you'd just what's the reflection still
like oh bye check him out and see what
it says
personal preferences like attraction yes
like how attractive are you really
why do you gonna date him if you weren't
attracted to him there's other qualities
in men or in a person that are important
like really important like how well like
you're compatible how well you can talk
to this person how intellectual they are
that sometimes are even worth more than
attraction to some women like personally
i do think like someone can i know
convince me with their like personality
and the way they talk more than how
attractive they are so that's why you
would go on this maybe date
even if you don't know if you're
completely attracted to that person
yeah so on your maybe date would you go
halves and it may be a date yes
not if you want to depend on me
i
are never hot like they never cost a lot
of money like i think the last first
date i went on we went to get drinks i
don't drink so he bought me a ginger ale
like
don't drink that doesn't make a big
difference yeah
or it's like coffee or like and i've
actually i'm an advocate of coffee dates
yeah i like coffee days
i think they're good because you're
talking a lot of dates
don't go in that direction that you can
go to the movies like you said you can
go somewhere that's too loud and you
don't actually get to talk a lot and
with coffee you can just sit down it's
just a normal conversation and
you're quite casual everything's quite
calm i think it's a good place to start
for example to get a coffee go someone
like put a bit of road
whatever he's giving tips little walk
around
and the date's going well then you can
stop for and then what happens is you've
gone from a coffee this was last like an
hour yeah actually it was like four
hours later you've had two coffees and
they're like well let's look at some
drinks then yeah
it's a whole day yeah
no like that's a good suggestion i'd
advise that to anyone listening like go
on a coffee date highly recommend 100
i've done bowling before i kind of like
bullying
i like i like fun days that's what i
meant to say
yeah i like i like i like active like
i'm a sports i'm a sport you guys are
naturally i like active day so when i
say like but i
lost last day that i've been on was like
when top golf it was you know the fun
was out we were still talking but i was
just like you know was you're doing
something yeah i like because i'm
naturally sporty so i would like to do
something with an activity involved you
know i mean like go go cutting or
something you know something you know
i'm really competitive so i don't think
that would go well for me
so like if we're doing a meeting i think
i would run in the day because i'd be
like oh like it's right now because i'm
very competitive in that nature as well
wouldn't that be would you prefer to
would you would it be more proton if he
beats you
would it be more of a turn and if he
wins in the game whatever you do i don't
know like i can be pretty ugly if i'm
losing
like i don't want to see that besides me
[Music]
like what i don't know like if i did win
like like okay what now i don't know
i've like
but yeah i don't know if it's a good
idea to do something competitive for a
first date for me personally maybe i
mean i might get angry you get to see me
mad right away yeah yeah
i imagine
you're mad but i i still think you'd
prefer to be mad in love and lose and
win and be like oh beat this guy up i
don't know
i think he'd go like boys he wouldn't
like go boxing
whatever you're doing
i mean like i think just like having
like an activity for the first day is
nice because like it kind of you kind of
avoid like the awkward like science
science yeah it's kind of bonding yeah
and then you have something to talk
about too like oh like huh like i'm
better than you
at least it was a [ __ ] day you got a
memory out of it as well yeah yeah
you know like depending on like
like what your sense of humor is maybe
like to [ __ ] talk or like yeah you can
kind of get their personality a little
bit more also i'm sorry i'm sorry if any
any sporting game i trash talks like i
can't believe i trash talk and i will
trash
you were trash talking 15 year old
okay i was trash talking them who was
bullying them in the past
okay so we went so a couple of weeks ago
right me and her went down to my regular
sports hunter right to play basketball
and then there was like a couple of guys
there where we play and stuff like that
let me jump in i was like i'll i'll take
her with my team and stuff like that and
she was just like working in the post
like that right i just kept giving her
the boo and she's just posting them up
and just laying there posing them up and
laying i'm like what the [ __ ] what is
going on
and then i think they're kids i think
they're taking they were actually not
they were in college they were like 17
18 years old
i think they were taken back because
like i'm pretty strong and most guys
like don't really expect that yeah and
so no i was i'm i had them sealed they
couldn't do that
it was
like all jokes aside there is a video
called um
what was the youtube channel i think it
was like on uh honcho nation the youtube
channel or something like that so yeah
go check it out
they cut out no they kind of they cut
out everything they only put it when we
were like
like nice nice no every every missed
shot they like put all together and i'm
like did you not you missed the part
where i i bullied you
like the funny thing is yeah every
single time ever since then yeah they
every time they come in to play they
don't they don't they don't they don't
even know they play with me they just
don't bring out the camera no more
i mean it's not on camera did it even
happen
exactly
um okay there's one more super chat
question from mgtow by logic again guys
all super chats are towards a new camera
so we can get multiple angles in here
really appreciate it
um okay so at what point after a woman
meets a man does she owe him honestly
her thoughts and feelings about him
like i wouldn't say like oh oh my god i
had a guy ask me this on the first date
he's like so what do you think of me i'm
like
no i was like
i feel like no one should be answering
those type of questions because like you
can't like from from the first date when
you meet you can't really
this is awesome
because you don't you don't know that
you don't know them you you
you don't know them at all like you
don't owe them an explanation of what
like it's the same as asking like
what are we the first week that you've
been you've seen each other it's like
it's it's a better question to ask is
like is there a second day because then
you're not asking okay like what do you
want like you're showing interest like
do you want a second day like what that
my gosh where are you guys sorry yeah
um at what point after a woman meets a
man does she owe him honesty in her
thoughts and feelings about him
yeah did you okay
i think um
because like every like
relationship or situation i guess
kind of rolls at different timings
and i would say like why would you want
to force someone to tell you how they
feel like shouldn't they be the one to
open up to you instead of like you know
tell me how do you feel about me like
wouldn't you rather have them like have
feelings for you and just be like
wanting to tell you you know i feel like
a lot of guys don't like listen to the
signs
where it's like i don't think we can
suppose
i think they just need like you just
full-on just be like i like you
men don't actually like to read into
things i think women do
but like men choose not to so two or
constantly just don't know how to yeah
i've interpreted that question in a very
different way okay i interpret it as in
like if you just met someone in the
first day you come back to the first
scenario
like should you tell him immediately or
at some point after the day mm-hmm well
i'm not feeling you listen without doing
this again rather than deep feelings i
think you guys went for a more emotional
deal oh trash
as well
so like during the day like okay let's
say we're on a date like during the day
we're like i'm going to go now because
i'm not feeling the day like i feel like
that would be like really i'd rather no
no no you don't see that you don't see
that right there buddy i think the
question is more like well after you had
a date
like when somebody's like what when do
you keep talking or stringing it long or
she should it be honestly actually no
that that we're loving meeting you and i
don't want to see you again i think it's
good courtesy to like um after the date
to write to them and tell them okay i
enjoyed the day or i didn't enjoy the
letter yeah like okay you get your you
can't get that
so just like send them a message and
like oh i enjoy the day i would like to
have a second day i enjoyed the date but
i don't think we'll have a second date
that's basically the bare minimum but
what what house you know i think again
my interpretation it might be different
one to the daughter subject that's what
how soon after the first day the next
day
i don't like a guy i'd just text them
right out like afterwards
yeah just like get this done
i just let them know the next time they
ask me or if they even do ask me you
know
i just i don't know i'm
i'm very non-confrontational so i know
what you mean i feel like it's quite
difficult as a woman to kind of
i don't know yeah to like break things
off because men will make it the memo
make it easier they're like oh like i
don't want to see you again like why i'm
like but
isn't this enough
i don't want to get more feedback so you
said something three months ago so you
um dance you said something i'm gonna
challenge it it's not that men don't
want to see signs and read signs we're
not as good at reading inside and seeing
sounds yeah
it's not we're not that we're not we
don't we don't want you so we're not as
good as it as you are so you might be
putting signals out but we just miss
them i'm sure yeah
it's better example would have liked a
guy seen a guy liked him and you think
you did the most to get his attention he
ain't [ __ ] seeing it he's not he's
not yeah he's like oblivious to it
sometimes it's gonna be we
you have to be sometimes to be quite
obvious and quite blatant with us
because we're not picking we don't get a
subtlety sometimes yeah but i do feel
like
i mean like someone can
i mean i think like just men are they're
just naturally more like logical and
they don't do the
like what does this mean what does this
mean does this mean like we can do a lot
of things but pick up on like little
hints they don't yeah they don't do the
over thinking that we kind of do like we
think like oh everything like kind of
not everything but like you know yeah
you're like you're looking at the
details thing you may really look at the
details and then kind of look at the
general picture what something means so
for example you've got a partner right
have you ever been if you're in a way of
your partner and like walked a room with
like women and you've like seen them or
got a vibe from them that they're
watching your your man and you're like
she's a [ __ ]
no we're just talking to have a nice
conversation and you see more than you
know is the territorial thing funny that
you say because the other thing like it
was like switched around oh really yeah
and i was like oh like i'm just like
talking to my friends and they're like
and he's like
friends i'm like yeah like friends like
they're not your friends i'm like
[Laughter]
if a guy and a girl are in a
relationship right can can the girl have
guy friends and can can the boy has yoga
women do you think like men can really
be friends with women at this point
i'm sorry i i had to just throw it out
and throw it out like this otherwise but
now like i just changed i think okay i
think most of the time no but there are
a few exceptions
family friends
i think like if you grew up together you
can have genuine friendships i think
growing up together can lead into that
religion you know into the it can yeah
but but i think like there are genuine
friendships where you grew up together i
think there are genuine friendships
where
like sometimes people just live by each
other and like they just become friends
that way yeah like like next one i
become things yeah like or they're in
the same
like friend group i think those are the
three ways where genuine friends happen
like maybe like the sexuality or it's
not
you're not the preference so let's say i
don't want to say like the time like gay
best friend that's kind of weird but
like if someone's like not your
preference and you're best friends
but you put them in a friend zone they
usually still might want you so the
question still exists can they still be
friends because
he doesn't want to be a friend
i don't understand but then i think okay
if that was the case though i don't
think that so like we wouldn't know that
would be the case and then so then we
won't pick up on that we will push that
and so like would it be would it really
be our fault if like we're still we
considered like naive yeah really
a moment ago we just agreed that women
have better pickup signals and they both
gonna tell me that you can have a guy
for not knowing he's attracted to you
but i would say like expect
first of all i would say like when you
kind of like categorize that like person
as like a friend then then you say that
you don't see any other signal i
understand that you criticize him as a
friend but you still know that he wants
more than oh if i knew
even
choose like attractive friends or like
they'll only be friends with attractive
women if they're going to be friends
with them so that's why i'm really like
because they want you that's why
yeah so this is why i'm suspicious of
guy friends like both ways like i'm
watching out because i i thought it was
innocent but now i see through the lines
yeah i'm sorry it's never innocent
i mentioned this like on one of the
podcasts i've been on before i was like
it sucks sometimes like being a woman
like trying to be friends with guys
because you never know when they
secretly just want to [ __ ] you all the
time
but like in the end when that does
happen it just sucks because then like
you see all these things that you've
done with them and they're like okay i
actually didn't mean anything because
all you wanted to do was [ __ ] yeah and
it's kind of lousy because they went all
this way like they're playing the long
game the longest of games just to [ __ ]
you like that which is
so which is a bad strategy guys that
doesn't work keep that in mind
have you ever had a guy make it at the
friend zone short and sweet oh wait
actually i have
[Applause]
you didn't end up with him so no i did
not that is bad how did he get out of
the friend zone how did he get out of
the friends
because i didn't reject him because i
wasn't attracted to him i thought he was
very attractive i rejected him because
he he was like
too much of a horror so
weakness from you
and so and like three and he'd been just
pursuing me for like years at that point
so i was like oh and maybe he actually
like likes me you know what i mean
because it's been like three years okay
that's a long time to talk about longer
it's a long game to play was it worth it
was the whole reputation
was the whole this whole his whole
reputation did live up to the reputation
of being a [ __ ]
nothing happened like that with like no
i mean it ended for um different reasons
but
but that wasn't why like it didn't work
out but um
yeah i guess that like like but i
rejected him for a different reason it
wasn't because i wasn't attracted to him
okay that's not like your typical male
friend you know what about like have you
had a female friend that you've known as
a friend and then you've changed men
don't put women in friend zones
yes
yes they yes they yes they do yes they
do listen now listen listen yes they do
they just sleep with them yes exactly
yes yes
[Music]
and you're no longer interested in
having a casual relationship with her
but you're on good terms yeah she's a
friend now isn't she yeah it's different
and she's also casual sex
no but you're no longer having casual
sex because they're stopped for some
reason and you're still you're still
amicable that's a female friend yeah
that that that that and they're kind of
close that happens
but the difference is opposite of women
so you will put a fair guy in a
friendzone without [ __ ] him first
okay
so what are the categories that you guys
put women in friends with benefits
of benefit like and then like possible
relationship and that's it and then
that's what whoa really
someone that you'd want to have kids
with and then like friends with benefits
and then let's say like wifey like what
is wifey category what do you mean how
did you get from friends with benefits
to wifey what happened
that's all i see right there
on that so you've never met a girl that
you know you were not attracted to but
you're like oh this is a really cool
girl i want to be her friend like i want
to like you know play basketball with
her like play like you know whatever
or like you know drink some rum
and a blue moon type thing so what first
the first thing i say to you is this um
you i think one of you mentioned because
you mentioned earlier on um
but you might you said you said maybe
someone have you
and someone might speak you might
retreat to them because they may say
things and do things yeah difference
what what difference is this
as as men we're attracted to what we see
right we much up to what they hear
so we can tell sweet last women and they
fall for you even though they're not
trying to you might not be trying to see
him he said the right words and he'll
get you yeah we don't that same thing
doesn't work with us we like what we see
women's fight or flaw
i do love me a good sweet talk
in mind right when you see a woman yeah
we're seeing them in pretty much two
different ways we will give when most
men all men give women attention right
because
you like it actually without giving
attention right yeah but what would the
thing that
i'm gonna say all but i think when women
get confused they confuse
sexual attention
with romantic attention so that's
because you give attention doesn't mean
that we like you just want to [ __ ] you
but like just different to us want to
wife you yeah but how would we know
because let's say how look let's say
you've got tinder a guy will only swipe
on you if he's attracted to you and you
got your first date like very quickly
how do you know this person's intent
without being pushy that's really
difficult to find out because if a guy
okay it's only interested you sexually
first off the fact that how do you know
i'm going to say something to you then
answer your question so i'm going to say
if i say two is dating is stupid they
think we're stupid oh dating oh dating
isn't it so it serves no purpose it's
it's redundant doesn't make any sense
your grandpa your grandparents they got
married quickly had long race ships
dating doesn't work well then why aren't
you married
[Music]
what else have you been doing the last
15 years that's difficult we have done
different books
okay you said dating is stupid dating is
where you do it
yes but it serves no long-term purpose
okay
so when do you say what do you want from
a guy well the question you say is
the question to ask yourself is what
you're doing
are you dating for purpose
why are you dating what what what is
your end goal from day so i have to ask
this on a date so if i'm on the first
one
what
why are you dating somebody why are you
going on dates what is what do you want
from dating to meet someone i like for
what what what what's it what's the loss
of end game
husband right so you then have to when
you meet a guy you have to be explicit
say to say to him i'm dating to be
married
okay if he's not going to be married
he's wasting your [ __ ] time
so how would you know that from the
philippines
but
you don't guess you don't assume
you meet him in a bar you meet him
online
i am only dating to be married if you're
not on this you waste some let's not
there's not waste money but when you say
like that kind of like scary yeah that's
always gonna that's what's gonna say it
scares a lot of us off but i don't want
to be like married like now like i'm
saying like could be like four to five
years like that's the end game
yeah relationship long term for every
four to five years if you don't if
you're not safe if you're not explicit
in your and what you want as an outcome
every time you meet somebody you're just
drifting along
you might be around four or five years
so you've wasted a year of someone that
was never interested in getting married
in the first place so if you're not
explicit about what you expect as an
outcome then how can outcomes you want
you need to be you say right this is
what i want
if you're not on this plan then there's
no point you join you know no point you
talk to me because this is what one at
the end of it yeah but like lies in the
audience do you think it's a bit like a
bit overbearing so on the first day if
someone says to like oh like i want to
get married and someone has to kind of
like gauge if they want to get married
i didn't say to you i want to get
married i said to you i'm dating to be
married i'm only dating to be married
but i think like how can i marry you but
i'm only dating
a bit too high i feel like it makes that
puts a lot of pressure no no but you're
what you're doing is filtering the guys
who have no intention of being married i
guess it's just something
i would say like even even mentioning
like the word married would freak him
out and it would freak me out if a girl
was like yeah i like i don't remember
does dana guy and he was like oh like he
was talking about like a proposal like
on the first day yeah really freaked me
out
even though i was i had similar
intentions if you know what i mean i
would say like you know the first thing
you would say like oh like i'm trying to
get in a relationship and then you know
maybe a few days later you can be like
oh like do you ever oh there we go yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah um
oh like you know are you maybe like
looking to get married but you wouldn't
say it on the first date yeah that's not
really a first date i don't think it's a
discussion yeah then i'm going to tell
you both you're very wrong and you're
very flawed and never if that's what you
want you're not going to get what you
want my life you're going to go through
life just drifting
but so i mean i'm telling you you know
men do get scared
i think men also have autonomy in like
what's going on in the relationship and
i feel like a man just like okay because
the woman hasn't said
explicitly that she wants to get married
that it's off the table i think a man
should be able to also make that
decision as well so i feel like just
saying putting the whole thing in the
woman's hands is probably not fair you
missing something i'm not saying to you
you want to marry him i'm not saying
you're going to propose to him i'm just
going to make it clear for example i
don't want children right so whenever i
meet somebody i make it absolutely
[ __ ] clear that it's not going to
happen
if you want to date me knowing that
that's fine i mean i feel like i respect
that i respect that that's the same
thing so if you know you want to be
married if not as to what you want out
of life then why are you dating guys
that doesn't want to be married
well i don't know but you don't know
because you don't tell them that's what
i want that's what you want
i guess do you think that's common
though i don't think it's like no i'm an
etiquette for a first date no no and i
just why you flush why women that's why
you flew that's why no but i'm i'm
talking about
let me finish
i'm talking about the people i know that
are married
most of like my uh my brother is
i would say gonna get engaged this year
he's 28
yeah he's
like and the way like they he him and
his girlfriend just like met in college
dated for four or five years and like
now they bought a house probably gonna
get married
um and like same with my other brother
it was like the same thing
so i just like i don't know i'm not
saying you're wrong to be honest because
i actually like agree with you on some
level
but like devil's advocate i don't know
anyone that did that that got married
and that's like my parents that's how
they met in college dated four or five
years yeah married
even they're also married so you are
different generations so what i say to
you well this is like my brother's 28
like that's the same generation
don't try it don't try she's on you
she's on you don't try it
she's landing a couple
what i say in response to that is this
um so how would you react to someone
said like i want to get my intention is
to marry on the first date like how
would everyone react to that because i
feel like that's what hey that's
like what do you mean
how's your response
yeah
[Music]
and like this guy he didn't even mention
married but he was like oh yeah like i'm
trying to like travel the world with my
significant other i'm like
i'm like i don't know you like why
like what yeah
now for me it's like
a time in the place is not necessarily i
take it as face value what i mean by
that is
if someone tells you it comes up to me
you know like wait on the thursday and
says oh i'm dating to get married cool
a big turn off for personally for me is
when a woman knows like what she wants
so if i tell you time in the place i
mean really mean it's like look i'm
looking to get married in the next this
amount of time i'm looking to do it like
this i want this like i will know what i
want out of this out of a relationship
and stuff like that that's a really big
turnout for me personally turn off or
turn up turn on
you know what you want out of this
relationship i know what i wanna when i
go into a relationship i know what i
want i wanna you know i wanna i wanna
date i wanna you know have someone to
come back home to you to marry to love
to have kids to build a family in the
next
eight years right but i know that right
and when a woman comes along with the
same energy that is just a really big
plus
i guess it can work out really well if
you're both on the same level so if the
person also has like that same intent
and he's very forward as well then i
think it makes a lot of sense but i just
don't think in the uk we have that kind
of culture to be that forward so it just
comes across a bit
a bit strange actually that's nice so
you want to be married you want to be
mad at some point no not that married
married but like in a very committed
relationship
what yeah i want to get married
time to place
time in a place before
before that time and before it's in mind
before 30 yeah okay hopefully yeah
do you have a time and place in mind it
is eight years i wasn't saying did you
you just described it
when i first started thinking about it i
was like like very young yeah but like
my me and my friend was like just like
just joking around and i said i was like
i want to be
have a kid when married like bef so when
my kid is born i can still be the you
know the cool dad
you know someone that you know that you
know i don't want to be that guy that's
like oh dad let's go through a bull and
i'm and i'm like all rusty like walking
around like
it's this bad thing
oh want to be active i want to you know
pick my son up and like outrun him in a
race and be man and talk [ __ ] to him
when he's young you know i want to be
that dad i don't want to be that dad
that sits on the couch all day drinking
beer and watching tv no that's not no
[ __ ] speaking
facts such a vivid picture so
ladies do any of you have like friends
in their 30s yes
yeah i don't think i do they're friends
and authorities that are unmarried but
would like to have been married already
or want to be married
um so far i mean so far i don't really
know i think they want to have kids but
they don't necessarily want to get
married they're more like they've gone
past that point
i mean i don't know
yeah we haven't really had that
discussion but i mean she's single and
she's dating
like or like in kind of like talking to
someone you know like whatever that's
someone because there's like a marriage
inflation with our generation like i
feel like every generation seems to get
married later and settle down a bit
later so i feel like we need to like i
feel like i should face that in mind and
probably not want to get married so
early i think before 30 might be a bit
too much optimistic actually i think
you're flawed because i think i think
your opinion on that is flawed okay
explain
i can explain
badly when how old do you think you
should how would you think you should be
to have children
i think the best day just probably is
young like
above 18 but below 30.
so if you want to be have children
before why do you be mad why do you have
children before you are married
i don't think it matters it greatly
matters
why i mean it depends on what your
values are because you have more
security from a husband yeah if he walks
away from you after your marriage still
you have much more rights to him than
than if you're not married
yeah exactly takes half your sheep i
know
and significantly more likely
completely self-sufficient and i
wouldn't need to marry someone to have
that security so let's say security is
not an issue
having kids work before or after
marriage doesn't really make a
difference so
statistics shows that people who come
from married or generally speaking dual
parent house comps households say
children and those upbringings have a
better output in life than children from
single parent households
for yours but you want me to parent
you'll still be in a marriage but you're
just married after you've had the child
but why did i wait right so let me let
me
it doesn't matter what's the bigger
commitment having someone's name or
giving someone a child what's the bigger
commitment well can you repeat that
what's the bigger commitment given
somebody's being married or having a
child what is a bigger choice in life
i think it's having the child so why do
you have the harder thing before the
easier thing
i just because it doesn't matter when
you do the easy thing but if it's easy
to do the easy thing first no
i think it doesn't matter
you might get married not like him and
then divorce him no big deal we have a
child or something you don't like
anymore you still touched him for 18
years so why do you have the child first
about being married
i don't think that makes much sense i
think you can get divorced after if you
don't like the person wait that could be
get divorced
that's at the expense of the child that
is true i think divorce has a
significant effect on the child and i do
think that if you grow up in a single
parent household you do have a different
sort of childhood because one parent
doesn't have the other person to like
bounce off like they can be too strict
or too lacks and i do think that's a
real thing
but i do think that you can get married
and be in a committed relationship
and have a child and then without a
child also be in a committed
relationship with the child you know i
think you missed a question i asked if
you give me honest respect for every
question i asked if marriage is easy
before forget the children for now
you're married someone it doesn't work
out after three or four years you walk
away no problems yeah right
that's easy
having a child or someone wherever
you're married you've tried someone
wherever that guy's a dick and you hate
him after a year you realize he wasn't
the one for you yeah right you're still
have been linked to that man for 18
years at least so why would you get mad
why would you not get married first
and will could maybe be able to walk
away with lesser commitment than have a
child with a greater commitment i feel
like somebody that's like kind of a
special case i haven't really i mean i
don't know really what situations are
but i feel like usually when you have
a child before me are just like not
intentional maybe like my people like my
parents
[Music]
like i mean that's not a bad thing and
then you get like you can still like
like i mean obviously you still like
choose to keep it but i mean it doesn't
i feel like it's just a special case i
think that now that we're having
children so much later in life yeah i
feel like it doesn't matter so we're a
bit more mature like the average age to
have a child now it's probably a lot
older than when my parents would have a
child i think that's why it doesn't
really matter when exactly the child is
born because normally it's later than
the average anyway i've got parents
i just think like you can't there's no
way you can accidentally have a child in
2022
say like you know you do all the right
things and then you still get pregnant
like you know maybe they don't want to
have the abortion so they choose to have
the kid but then you know they don't
feel like quite ready they're gonna be
unhappy so you're telling me like
condoms and birth control you know
someone that's gotten pregnant on both
but also i mean like not everyone takes
birth control not everyone wears condoms
that's all that's in the uk now right i
don't know how it is for your
international students
but in the uk do it and i'll stand by
this and people can add me what they
want to you cannot have a baby packs in
the uk you can never work you cannot you
can say it you can not have a child by
accident in the uk
well i mean i used to have a child in
the uk because yeah contraception is
free condoms the pill we're getting
there
wait wait let me finish quantums are
if you don't have that you have you get
reckless
one nafta is free
everything in the uk in terms of
reproductive rights are free so if you
choose to do any of those things you
have made a conscious decision to have a
child yes over here you cannot try
backstage but i didn't say by accident i
said unintentionally
so you can't no it's not because yeah
like naivety like something can happen
that you're not aware of let's say
you're not conscious or let's say like
you are very naive you don't know to
monitor your cycle you don't know if
you've missed the period some people
just don't pay attention to those things
there's people okay abortions are free
yeah some people don't even know they're
pregnant yeah so like abortion so you
chose to have a child but okay but
that's the thing that's why you choose
you choose oh you let me talk
so i'm not saying like it was by
accident i'm saying they unintentionally
got pregnant and then they chose
against their values to like have an
abortion so like it wasn't even a choice
let's say
yeah
it's not a choice but some some people
it's not even choice if they wouldn't
think about having an abortion it's not
on the table let's say they're very
catholic well that's that's how my
parents were but but but you can't
no um like my parents my parents my mom
got pregnant when she was um 17 but she
still chose to give up that kid for
adoption
so like you still have adoption even if
you have the kid do you know in the
bible it talks about having adopted um
having abortions
i don't know where that's coming from
like
numbers nine says if you're up and
someone can look it up and give the
exact bible a reference well i think
it's number nine is something says
something in the lines of if you have a
wife and you believe she is cheating as
a baby she should go see like a witch
doctor take a potion and get rid of the
baby so the bible talks about having a
baby
what does that mean for people that
aren't religious like you're saying that
you put religion up i didn't bring
religion out who brought up having
how did you know i did say i mentioned
that some people don't believe that what
i'm saying some people like that she's
saying that some people don't believe in
abortion so that's why they choose to do
it so people can't afford some people
can't afford an abortion so let's say
this doesn't take no
no you're in the oh but we're talking
about the yeah how about only these two
i'm just saying in the uk there's not
the funding of it isn't an issue because
yeah the nhs you have to worry about the
funding of it it's not that's not that
it's not a debate
but something you know what is there
some shoes some some fears some females
choose to like keep the baby for the
foot like
it's it's the right reasons for them but
it's the wrong reasons for the guy
because what they're doing is like
um you got me pregnant
i'm gonna keep the baby and i'm just
gonna you know graciously accept your
child donations every month they do you
know what i mean but if you're saying
like if they're not married yet so then
and you said that only once you're
married then they actually have like
something you have to be child support
regardless you have to support
regardless
as a wife than your mother
because for example my parents had me
there wasn't like there wasn't married
when they had me as well so
but you also have adoption like you can
give up a kid for adoption if you don't
believe in abortion
that's what my parents did
[Music]
poor greg
he's involved with us now like we like
read yeah yeah we like yeah that's what
i said like you ended up bring him back
into your family yeah yeah but like i
respect that someone made a decision
like i can't take care of this child i'm
going to put them in the hands of
someone that can take care of the child
i really respect that the people that do
that so
kudos too
but i i still i agree with you like i
think that if you get pregnant it's a
choice on some level you either made the
choice to be irresponsible
and yeah like at some level you made
that choice
yeah i think definitely take
accountability yeah your own
contraception your own health and sexual
safety i think that's the bare minimum
do you guys think abortion is used as a
form of birth control today rather than
an emergency i don't think i don't think
so
i don't know
statistics but i feel like it's kind of
a traumatic experience and i don't think
women would intentionally want to have
an abortion
i think i feel like the more like
uneducated people maybe like the more
like then they use it like for that but
i mean for people that have gone through
like sex ed or whatever classes like
i mean they know
like what the body is there can i just
pause it for a second sex education in
high school in the uk is absolutely
atrocious it is i'm so sorry i am so
sorry when i went to high school and for
those of you that went to high school
about maybe i don't know four or five
years ago everybody knows they give you
this little
penis plastic and they show you how to
roll on i don't believe no it's not sad
ever it's it's way better and it's just
so uncomfortable can i hear that again i
don't believe in sex ed in schools what
do you believe in them i believe that
your parents should be in charge of that
i don't think the government should come
in i would not have i could i could not
have no i would because
as a girl as a girl as a girl you know
the creepiest teachers were always the
gym teachers i think that
well i just think i just think okay if
you're like you're giving predators
access to children you're blowing my
color right now what but it's just no i
know it's going to be teachers like
period well i know but you can't do it
but i know but like you can't filter
that out and i just think like you're
giving predators and act like men and
women predators access to children at a
very young age
and like why like i don't understand
what a stranger is going to teach my
kids better than i can teach them
uncomfortable from you to get rid of
your parents though
but a stranger is not better nobody
doing it in school on the safe under
like you know it's on this like as safe
as you guys it's one thing right but i i
don't i don't know one kid
would that i would want like i would
personally would never want my mom or my
dad or anyone of my family to come up to
me and be like this is how you put a
condo i would never want to hear that i
would never want to hear them come to me
and be like this is what sex is this is
how you do it because you want to hear
that from a stranger and then two two
the other thing is every girl that i
know that's had an abortion honestly had
the most educate like one of them one
one of them was a nurse one had the most
education and the most accessed
information and they were just
irresponsible like they were just
irresponsible like yeah can i ask the
question
[Music]
is there any level of certification that
you think should be provided by schools
no none
like outside of biology like but like
biology and sex education would go hand
in hand so it's kind of hard to pull
them apart
trying to understand yeah
are you saying are you trying not
like okay wait did you do the line we
had we had no sex out at my high school
we had no problem like no pregnancy
as in like
have you been pregnant before and that
worked have you been pregnant before no
okay no no i'm sorry i'm just awesome
because you didn't yeah
well i mean i could say no
and that's that's what i'm saying like
like if if the theory is that sex ed
helps get rid of unplanned pregnancies i
have not seen data to indicate that it
helps and if anything it was the
opposite because abortion rates have
gone up and when they and when sex had
entered schools it wasn't like
teen pregnancies drastically reduced and
wait okay sorry but would you say like
abortion rates have gone up just because
like the laws have changed now and now
like it's become like more like open for
people to get them because like i know
before like
it was it was like against the law for
like and it was very stigmatized
why people would just do it like secret
maybe they just don't keep track of it
now
i mean before i if i had to guess i
don't know but if i had to guess i think
it's because people are more reckless
every like
when i
when i talk about on the show just like
wearing condoms like guys are always
like oh no like
and it's just like people don't even
wear condoms when they have sex with
random people i thought i feel like you
don't even i feel like that's a bit uh
unfair and that's this is coming from
like from the women's side
i'm more on the one side now because it
shouldn't have to be a case of like oh
i'm not choosing to work on this oh it
should be practice safe sex type thing
so like if a woman says like like strap
up like i you have to respect her wishes
i'll be on you know i mean but then like
what most guys do what i used to do when
i was yeah
um
i
i prefer not to wear a condom right
because it doesn't feel as natural as
they would say right
but like the way of most of you
right but you have you you know but you
have the information to know it's better
right yeah but you just prefer it but
that's that's what like i don't think
any amount of information is gonna
you know but the information
was gonna get you is because because
most men think think like this right
like i don't have to wear it because now
like like you said now we have the plan
b peeled the morning off yeah
right
what's it called the birth control the
injection and stuff right implants yeah
so why would i need to use a car like
most men like why would i usually use a
condom if you can just oh pop a pill
like i mean yeah you know but at the end
of the day i think stds is the answer
yeah yeah pretty much yeah but i'm just
saying like i just i genuinely there
there's so much information we have the
internet we have like and i don't i just
think people don't want to practice safe
sex even if they have the information
i do think it should stay in schools
though because i feel like it's good not
to sense information from children i
think
because some homes maybe it's just not
like different cultures different
backgrounds might talk about sex at
different ages and i feel like sometimes
they might miss the mark where the kid
is gonna start feeding
who knows you better than your parents
your parents know the kid better than to
have the best interest of the kids
let me finish and they let they have the
best interest of the kid out like they
have more incentive to have the kid turn
out to be a good person that a stranger
is going to have so you're going to why
does the stranger know when the best
time to introduce sex into that kid's
life like educate them and all that
stuff like why do they know better than
the parents it's kind of the policy of
the school right now
in that school so maybe with that in
mind right so a group of strangers like
why did why do they know better than
than the parent but the information
doesn't change no it's just more
sensitive
no no what was going to say it was like
the reason why i said i i reached you to
some extent right but
when i said that um the sex education in
the uk is atrocious
what was my point was to that right is
because when the actual day everyone
gets a notification or whatever like oh
we're gonna have sex education this day
and then i would my travel if it was a
stranger i wouldn't travel it would be a
professional
person or or governing bodies right
there a sense of person that knows about
education who's trained in that to talk
to you about it rather than have your
maths teacher or your geography teacher
showing you how to put a
condom on on on our facebook have you
guys seen sex education yes it's a great
it's a great difference like i do like
the concept that having like maybe a sex
educator come into school so make a huge
difference and it's also like you would
respect the information more so if
you're having your geography teacher
your homeroom teacher tell you you
should do it this way this way you're
like why would i most of the most of the
guys
like all of that
yeah i also want to bring a point that
you like brought up like you know
sometimes like family households they
have like different cultures and like
for instance like my family like we
don't we wouldn't bring we don't talk
about this kind of thing so like i
didn't know anything like the only thing
they would be like oh don't have a
boyfriend until you get to college don't
do this don't do this don't do this and
then obviously being the rebel that i am
what's what's your boy what's up what's
your what's your cultural background
sorry i'm chinese malaysian so my mom's
from malaysia my dad is from china i'm
first generation american
and so you would see like where that
cultural difference is you know yeah
it's different to like western culture
without a clue yeah yeah what a rebel
without a cause
but i mean like that's where you would
like i like i mean like i literally like
learned everything through school like i
needed that what did like what did you
need to learn like i i i went to
catholic school we had no sex ed but i
just it's common sense like where kind
of i don't know
i don't think it's common sense for a
lot of kids because a lot of kids really
like their culture probably wouldn't
cover that thing and like
yeah
you watch on tv
if you live in the us or the uk you're
telling me you're not gonna hear what
birth control and condoms are i mean
like 13 i was like still climbing trees
like i was the the most tomboy
yeah yeah but also i was not interested
with sex education i can't i don't think
you can really say common sense because
you're so young and then like usually
when you're kids like you're just making
fun of all these things right you're
like so awkward yeah like you're doing
like you know yeah
oh that was the most that that's just
the most awkward thing there's one thing
about when they actually show you like
pictures and stuff like that and they
try to do them as a uh kind of like you
kind of learn like oh it's like this is
like a real thing and it's not really
like a joke and it's a serious thing you
know also for like sexual preferences as
well so at school in the uk you don't
really learn anything about like
homosexual relationships so let's say
you're homosexual like you wouldn't
probably learn that from your parents
either like what you should do so having
access to that it's all over the media
though but like like how would you want
your child to search up like oh how to
have sex as a matter with a man or how
to say no i don't but i don't want to
teach you teaching them that either
i mean i don't know like why does my 16
15 year old need to know that
no
probably doing it anyway that's what i
need to know i mean they know then they
don't know
what was going to say right is like you
know when um sex education wise right
they teach you about like the like the
first time right now the
how was
from what from what you was told from
what you
expected how was like your actual first
time because it wasn't really that all
that great personally for me the first
time that i've had it it was very
uncomfortable as you would say because
you you i was expecting you know like
birds and whatever
and it's like yeah but it wasn't it was
never like that so it was just like it's
just i i had a great time
oh yeah you just you lied that you know
i'm saying you're just heading do you
think you could have been like i do
think i get what you mean like there's a
lot of things that you see like what you
see in tv and what you learn in school
both things are really unrealistic like
there's no there's no middle in the
middle where you get like a balance of
both like okay it's gonna be like this
or it's gonna be like this it's not
realistic yeah because like the first
like honestly the first time that i've
had it right
it was it was uncomfortable because like
i was under the miscomprehension about
like i was watching a lot of movies and
you know like a lot of like the
sex education classes from whatever so
the first time in the movies and all
that stuff you know i was like oh
all of that and it really wasn't and it
was like you're looking at i'm like it's
just
is that something is it happening did it
happen like you know it's one of those
it's one of those weird things
i think that's where like where both
school and kind of like media really i
don't know
has no meat social media social media
has such a huge influence actually i
have a question so if you believe in sex
ed in school do you think they should
educate women on how like the more
partners you have the lower chance you
have at a happy marriage
i think that's a different topic i think
education should be like biological and
focus on that kind of aspect
and this relationship is probably more
of like a
philosophical topic well it's not like
it's like based on like like multiple
basics
no no i'm serious because if we're
talking about we're in sex ed we're
educating people on the ramifications of
sex right if you have sex with one
person you have an 80 chance of having a
happy marriage in 20 years if you have
sex with one it drops down to like 40
50. and if
it's more than five it's like 20 percent
and and so that's like a ramification of
sex so i'm asking like do you think
that's something you would add in sex i
don't know like sex ed should probably
like stray away from people's opinions
because it should be like strictly
focusing on like like data so that would
be data
no because that's like an opinion i feel
like that's going into the direction of
like this is what someone believes no no
no no studying that so there's if
there's multiple studies that were have
been peer reviewed by different people
that had nothing to do with each other
that came to the same conclusion you
wouldn't say that but let's focus on the
random implications on sex in a
relationship was just some focus on the
actual sex itself and i think sex
education should focus on the sex itself
okay like making that a healthy and safe
process i think that's probably a
different topic for a different part of
school i'm not sure where it would go
also i don't think when you're doing sex
like
sex education you shouldn't like i feel
like um you shouldn't try to like make
them like straight towards like doing
this doing something like influencing
that kind of way yeah
so you don't think teaching them how to
put on condoms is influencing them one
way but i mean that's like that's for
like protection you know i feel like
that's just something that they do
if they do what
what if they do what they're predicting
like if they do what
like that is influencing them one way
because you're teaching them how to put
on but you're not like telling like go
have sex you're just right
like how to protect themselves from
diseases and everything else so in the
same way i wouldn't tell them
like go be at chase it's just putting
the data out there and saying this is
like you can make your decision
basically okay yeah i feel like i feel
like in schools you should really stray
away from like kind of
influencing people because at that age
like people are very like i know myself
like at like 16 17 like whatever my
teacher told me like oh my god this is
so true like definitely listen to it and
if like at that age you need to be
careful what you like feed children
because they will take it with them you
know like you end up doing the opposite
yeah like they're very
the age is like a very vulnerable age
for like mindset and things like that
where did you go to school
near birmingham in the uk in the uk
um yeah california i'd say too i'd say
to you your school has really been you
have really been influenced by school
and anything you've learned
specifically in history is written and
they've been taught to in a biased slant
as and hasn't been the real
history that epic has existed in the
world history is written and expressed
by those who one who win wars yeah lots
of things that you've missed out on and
i don't fully understand so i hate what
you're saying about situation but
everything we learn
and listen to and everything we've
learned in school is it has a bias yeah
but like in birmingham for example there
was like a rule that they stopped
teaching
sex education about homosexual
relationships and there was like a huge
protest about it so like can you imagine
if you go to a school that don't teach a
certain aspect like the sense of their
education and go into a school that they
do like they don't like they do censor
information like there's a completely
different education that you're gonna
have but one way you can look at all the
information make your own choice and
then one way you don't even have access
to the information and i feel like
having access to information is always
better but then the thing is like um one
thing that i've noticed about like sex
education like in let's say for example
if it's like an oil or boys school or
girl school
um
because well i went to a public school
right and we when we had the classes we
would never have the class with the
girls because you know the girls were
learning and stuff like that but what
i've noticed right is the girls well
maybe it's always just my school but
what the girls only learned about the
female side of sex education type thing
like what's to do how to work what's
your body gonna go through this is how
to you know this is what a vagina looks
like you know that's that type of thing
and the boys only learned about the boys
side of things but they never intermixed
which is i feel like that's the wrong
way to go about it the girls need to
know about what the man is capable of
and what he how he works and the girls
and them
and what guys what are they i just don't
understand what does a 14 year old need
to know
sex education in the uk you only get
like 10 in year 10 which is like sickles
yeah but i would say
yeah but like at that age that's when
like you know puberty starts and
obviously like that's when kind of like
they get interested in the other sex
that's why it's so important you know
but also like backing to you like i
would say like from my school when i
learned about it we did do like about
men and women and not just oh one gender
she's from california yeah
because obviously okay guys i'm going to
read super chats
we got we got a bunch of super chats
okay eat garlic who even
another one um okay who even goes on
traditional dates anymore i'm just
human why'd you delete your message i
would have read it okay i'm sorry i
didn't get to your message fast enough
um just human
why do you get lazaro okay someone is
abusing my moderator powers because i
read that super chat earlier and it was
not bad i know it wasn't bad so don't
don't be deleting random comments for no
reason or i'm taking away the wrench
i know i saw it earlier okay
um okay next
pearly's brother i'm getting married
y'all
congratulations congratulations um
bozzie this is a significantly better
conversation than with jessica the other
night
um good job pearl nice to see everyone
you guys are mean
sentience my favorite donor sentience
goes hard with the super chats um
uh medically speaking a woman's peak for
reproduction is 18 to 24 once a woman
hits 30 over 90 percent of her eggs are
gone 35 plus is a g god damn 35 35 plus
is a g
geriatric
i i got it
with increased chance of birth defects
over 40 is very dangerous for mother and
the child
uh raphael um pearly's looking like a
snack though thank you
thank you
straight out of here man
thank you sentience another
okay um women especially in the us have
the option to divorce at any time for
any reason that includes having half of
his assets given to a woman over 90 of
the time in divorces and with the child
support due to current laws men don't
want to get married
um especially you if you have this type
of super chat money um
nah he's coming for you po he's coming
for you
he wants you bad do you think that's
crazy money um okay your creepy gym
teacher um crap and i was just about to
ask pearly al
um sentience to the guests across from
pearl
your statement of abortions as birth
control is paternally um wait patently
false abort clinics in the u.s have
stats that clearly show young women use
that as a cheap birth control while
belaying and avoiding accountability and
responsibilities
um okay
sentience body count correlating with
decreased chance of relationship success
is data based it's been repeatedly
proven that it's a fact not an opinion
research pair bonding it's a huge
biological and emotional ramifications
um also torsha i saw you were watching
and i know you had a question you wanted
me to ask um i don't there's so many
comments on the chat i don't see it but
if you put it again i'll try to do it
lazaro pearl i didn't remove any
messages i don't know what happened
um okay well it said it was removed by
you
um so
i'm gonna this is your warning okay if
it's happened to another stream you got
two more strikes and then you're out
yeah if you guys have if the guys who
sent me the super chat want to dm me
what you said on instagram i'll look for
it so i can read it the next time i'm
not trying to step over y'all
okay
um so my next question
we we got all over the place today
um
we're having a chin wear glove
we're having a chin wag a chin wag
that's such a
okay so question for the men
do you think women lack femininity today
and is that in this way
okay you guys you guys have to let me
finish this
it's my show
okay like i have something do you guys
think
do you guys think women lack femininity
today and is that something you look for
when you're looking for a partner
tag you're it
do women lack femininity um
i'm going to say blankly i'm not going
to say a blanket yes but i do think a
lot of women have
forgotten how to use their sexual wilds
to get things from men your grandparents
and probably your parents would have
known how to do things as well that's
one thing
and wait can you repeat that sorry i
think i said i'm not going to use a
blanket statement and say all women have
lost your feminine character that's
quite the case but i think a lot of you
have a lot of you chasing this whole
boss babe thing
and
that aggressive sort of nature that
comes with being a boss bae don't really
work for men that's one thing and i also
think a lot of you lost how to
the subtle art of using your sexual
wilds to get what you want from sexual
wear agreed
have you have you not seen girls on only
fans no no that's one
that's the sexual world
you're not exactly
getting to
have sex with women
and the only fans you're not exactly
getting to have sex with a woman you're
just they're you're paying to watch them
present themselves on that so there are
ways that we can support speak to men to
get things that are men
that
can i have an example should we do that
though like it's not absolutely correct
didn't like that first of all
so for example
you can say to me hey d okay put the
bins out you say to me baby
[Music]
and a lot of women have forgotten how to
do that especially nowadays a lot of you
forgot no you know what those sort of
things
and that's where you've that's why i
think it's because where feminism went
because
there was like a time when feminism was
like okay a woman has to be like a man
to be respected and women really kind of
like started owning that and becoming a
lot more like men stopped dressing
feminine started wearing suits to be
respected like men i think that's
probably where that mindset probably
comes from is like lose the femininity
become more masculine and get respected
so i think that's where that lies i
think it's like women trying to find
equality and that going down this route
but like now we know like maybe it's
probably not the right route i agree
with that but so in a bit in the
business world in the work world that
may work for you but it doesn't work for
the relationship world because everyone
when someone was like a man why they not
just get a man
yeah
i'm just saying that just playing out
there i agree i i completely agree
because of course if you're looking from
a perspective of like
a woman has to like in back in the day
the woman knew her like you know oh
the way we do for somebody like you the
way you're talking and stuff like that
it's like oh baby or the honey whatever
like you know you used that type of like
she was sitting at home
now now nowadays from what i've seen it
was it was more like a table hey yo like
you some some girls like um tomboys
right like breasts they talk like
brilliant like for real like happy like
for example sometimes i'll be speaking
to you like i've seen i've seen uh i
know one of my friends um i'm kind of a
megan right i'd say i'm a tomboy are you
telling me
some boys would you say
sometimes hell no no i wouldn't i
wouldn't say you're a tomboy well you're
dunking on people so you gotta be
talking
what i'm about because i always i always
really enjoy like i i just tend to enjoy
things that guys like and i'm not really
into like makeup and but i still think
you still have a feminine element like i
still found you the right guy if the
right guy walked by right
i think you can do a lot with the eyes i
think hair playing is a bit you know
but that's like the most like
ghostbusters now now it's the eyes that
touch the cake
they're flirty
yeah but i think you're kind of flirty
with everyone i feel like i'm just being
nice i mean i think it's just my it's
just how i am yeah i know i know it's
like feminine though oh okay
that's why that's what i'm gonna call
you masculine yeah i think it's just
weird because like for like since i was
little i was always like the tomboy like
i was like you know i had an older
brother i'd literally like
this fight with him yeah
every woman at certain stages went
through that tomboy stage though
no as i said i feel like i feel like at
a certain point we might have been a
long term but i feel like every girl at
some point has got has been or will go
through like a tomboy stage-ish i think
it's just like pre-pubescent because
like everyone like proof person isn't
really like doesn't really go into their
gender that like i feel like the gender
roles or their gender types aren't that
distinct i think femininity masculinity
isn't that strong in like kindergarten
or like in like middle school like when
children are quite young you don't
really like okay he's acting very
masculine or acting very feminine and
that comes when you grow and mature
ladies so is it is is femininity a bad
thing i think feminist is great i feel
like a woman should embrace her
femininity and i feel like it's a shame
that we went through that phase that
women had to try and be like men to be
respected i feel like it's a shame that
we had to
like hide a femininity to have that kind
of respect because it is true like a
very feminine woman isn't respected the
same way
like just in the workplace in general
like in a professional world like a
woman's very feminine like oh she's a
blonde she's not very smart i don't know
i haven't had like i've found that girls
that are feminine in the workplace get
more favors from men
but that's at the cost of i don't think
this woman is intelligent enough to do
that by herself it's like i'm gonna help
her and slept with no not really like
because i just was uh and the only girl
in an office of like 25 people and when
i was working there the guys that were
kind of on the same like job as me they
would always tell me
that um i only got help with certain
things because i was a girl and at first
i kind of was like yeah whatever
but in hindsight like
kind of because all the managers would
like help me with whatever i wanted like
drop everything
do special like one-on-one time they
would ask for the same thing and be like
weeks
i'd get it yeah can i ask you girls a
question right would you respect a man
that's like feminine and it's an open
open about like his feelings like he's
not he's not afraid of black ops
it's not feminine no but i'm saying like
he's like he's sorry okay
would you would you be like would you
respect a man that's like open about
like his feelings and like he would he's
like not ashamed to like cry in front of
you and supply and stuff like would you
like no i'm not sure
no exactly yes that's the way that's
awesome
but like in front of you like he's he's
open about his feelings he's like you
know he's not afraid to cry something
you
know
i've been in a situation like that it
was just exhausting so i was like you
have so many feelings
okay
flip flip flip that on us yeah but when
you girls give us stuff and we just have
to sit there and we'd be like i support
you darling like
i think a lot of people that i mean like
i would say like you're pretty like i'd
say in touch with your emotions but
you're not like very emotional like you
know you're not like crying all over
yeah you know i would say like i'm all
public that way like i'm not i'm very i
keep everything inside and so like if i
were to have to deal with someone that's
very open about it i feel like that
would be a lot for me to deal with too i
think it just depends on how that person
also expresses their i think i think
there's a difference between being
emotionally unavailable like to a toxic
like extent like the point like okay
like this person's giving really mixed
signals this person doesn't know how to
act like a human being
then to being okay like i don't want to
express my emotions all the time like
sometimes i don't need to cry right now
sometimes but it's not a big deal
sometimes you can you know like work
through things it's not always about
expressing emotions in like big bits of
rage or being like too angry or those
kind of things i think it's about
balance like having the bare minimum is
expressing your emotions i'm happy i'm
sad i like this i enjoy this like being
direct then there's a difference between
completely hiding your emotions so that
the woman's like are you actually okay
so there's something wrong like always
to keep guessing i don't think that's a
positive but
what would you say would that be like um
like a red flag for some girls i think
it's a red flag if a man can't openly
talk about um what he's feeling i'm
saying to a girl like if a man is
actually like
he's not afraid to express his feelings
you know you're all emotional and stuff
like do you think someone goes that
would be like a red flag i mean i think
for some people maybe but i feel like
for me no i think it'd be quite
refreshing to have a guy express his
emotions if he's happy like i'm happy
like it doesn't have to be always about
something sad it can be like oh like i
really appreciate what you did today or
i really support you or like oh i got
frustrated when you did that can we talk
about this can we talk about about that
like it doesn't always have to be like
oh a guy cried because his mom died like
it's not just that because that's gonna
happen probably like what once also yes
right i wouldn't categorize like
emotional aspects
[Laughter]
i wouldn't categorize like being
emotional as like a red flag maybe it's
just like to
not i wouldn't say like overly emotional
but like you know maybe it's just not a
turn on or it might be a turn off for
the girl it's just
not used to it i think that's probably
why it depends on like personal
preference i just think it's how often
like that like how often is he
like like like three days out of the
five like three times
okay like like like once once a month
once
you can't no no
i think we're going into like
personality types here yeah i feel like
there's being emotional then just having
like that personality type that's kind
of like
you're affected by everything like a bit
like kind of like a snowflake that
everything's like the world's against
you or like like this isn't like i
respect my dad a lot right and he's like
not an emotional guy and he's always
really in control of his emotions and
i've seen my dad cry but like i can only
count
like maybe twice in my life yeah
and you may be seeing him cry yeah of
course
and
of course like i would respect that more
than like
once a month
i think sorry i think maybe it's like
without crying
like you respect the guys that are tough
like you you like
looking up to guys that like can handle
their emotions and just are tough
you like you like those type of guys
that like no matter how what type of
pain they're going through they'll be
like i'm fine yeah yeah the scene like
your house just burnt down the guy's
like it's calm it's fine no no
but that doesn't happen once a month
that's like a
once-in-a-lifetime way it happened yeah
like
like i think there's the same chances
that someone actually has to cry
this man is actually keeping us so much
[Laughter]
okay do you want to open up what do you
what do you have to say
a couple of things
um
don't come for me
let's park the extreme examples away the
extreme examples of a husband and
children dying yeah yeah that's nature
that's that's unlikely to most people's
that's let's say like your mom dies
let's park extremely things let's let's
talk about day-to-day so the problem the
issue with
guys being emotional is this
we don't know what your level of
tolerance is what your level of
tolerance is or your liberal
intelligence provinces so we don't know
from who we meet what you may think is
acceptable emotions or not
right
now
let me okay
so therefore
it's just a safe bet
to show as little as possible because
what you may think is too much you may
think is not enough
so let's keep it
give it level of stoic second point to
that is this
if you're quite emotional person if
you're going through emotions we both be
going for emotions whenever it's gotta
be level-headed and see the right the
the wood for the trees
some of us one of us have got to be able
to see okay you're going for some [ __ ]
one of us could be like you know what
the logical voice right so if we're both
going for our feelings we're worth going
for our feelings all the [ __ ] time
especially the same points
nothing's ever going to be accomplished
because you're both going to be writing
about what's now and not seeing the
bigger picture of things and seeing
what's really important one of us has to
be that person that can say that this is
an issue we can work through this that's
why this is where we work through this
so it's how we get so we power through
this pro this scenario is how we power
through this relationship issue just
very powerful powerful this money issue
whatever it is
one of us has to be able to say let's
just work through i think that's a
really strong point what you're saying
there but i also do think when you're
going through a relationship like you
have the same problems it's good that
someone can be the strong voice of
reason and say okay we're going to do
this
but i also think like if you go through
like a serious problem let's say
financial difficulty and the person
doesn't acknowledge the emotions that
are at play in that situation i do think
it could lead to like the relationship
breaking up altogether even if the voice
of reason makes sense and is logical i
do think it may cause the relationship
become distant because someone is not
acknowledging the real effects of what's
happening so i feel like emotions should
also be intertwined within the voice of
reason but like you have to acknowledge
them i think that's what we mean by
being emotional we're not asking for men
to cry we're just asking to men like
okay this has affected me i'm upset
i'm happy like just you know be vocal
about what's going on for your mind to
say right it's a problem we're going
through this is the planet we get
through it rather than sitting and
dwelling in the problem and saying oh
you don't have to [ __ ] has happened both
get upset about it you gotta we got a
problem with the relationship it's not
me
it's not mutually exclusive to be
logical and also feel at the same time i
do think you can have emotions and make
a decision so okay my car's crashed i'm
so annoyed but let's go to let's go to
the insurance call them up like
one doesn't mean the other one can't
happen
i'm sorry i'm sorry to drop here but any
any person that calls uk's insurance
you're done out here yeah like if it's
like no no no you and anyone that drives
a car will agree with me right in the uk
if you crash a car
i'm sorry
if you don't have a guest insurance
company you're i'm sorry you are done
out i think like you just need to be
able to acknowledge you i'm not asking
the guy to cry just like a knowledge
okay yeah this is upsetting this is good
this is bad like if someone's just not
acknowledging it's like what does that
do for me
like for me it shows me that this
person's also feeling what i'm feeling
it just doesn't mean that i'm like okay
i'm living with someone that doesn't
i think it's so even today and this
isn't like because i look up to my dad a
lot right yeah i like called him i was
freaking out because um i guess you
don't even know what happened to me
today
i i went you didn't do it
i went through hell and back to get you
guys this sound board tonight
and basically
the guy off of facebook didn't give me
the power cord so i went to go get it
today because he forgot and
yeah i left my id and my wallet and my
keys on the on the train and i know yes
i said super chats please
because i didn't even know if i could do
the show tonight
oh no don't do it
i didn't i didn't i didn't even know if
i could do the show tonight cause i was
locked out of my apartment
and and my the company was like
you know my the company was um closed
for the weekend because it's easter
yeah and i and i had my phone dead it
was a lot but anyways i i ended up
getting my phone charged and calling my
mom and my dad my mom's reaction was
like
like you should have had a spare key and
my dad's reaction was like okay you're
you're alive you haven't like lost the
limb it's okay and i was like i cried
i'm gonna lie to you
and um yeah and i was just like that
like stoic i just i i admire that in men
when they're like calm stoic they don't
get emotional that like because my mom
was like pissed because i'm like you
have to cancel like the credit cards you
have to do that and my like my mom was
like freaking out this is why this is
why i like dealing with that like i do i
do see what you mean that i do think
like having a voice of reason is
important but also like okay let's say
you're not having a problem let's say
it's like an event that's a positive
event let's say you get married and your
dad's completely stoic the whole time
let's say you give birth and you have a
child in your dad's right whatever just
another monday right let's go to work i
don't give too like he doesn't care
like someone to be happy for you i just
want someone to have the balance of both
positive and negative emotions so i i
love that i can call my dad and he can
give me like a voice of reason all that
stuff do this this and this but like i
wish there was a balance in between the
emotions of my mother and the the but
isn't it
wouldn't it be more valuable if your dad
is stoic all the time and he cried at
your wedding
like you don't mean versus that's good
emotion though that's that's that's like
that's what i mean like like it means
more if like if he's tough most of the
time and strong and then occasionally
you have that like glimmer of emotion
like i don't think that's true but then
like what does that say about your dad
like did he just say like he oh yeah he
bottles up with all his emotions
he controls them yeah but like because
we like a guy in control
i guess but i think he can be in control
and also experience emotions and express
your emotions like one of the times i
saw my dad cry okay this this literally
convinced me i i smoked weed once in
high school
of course you didn't yeah no i really i
i didn't even like it but my dad was so
mad at me he like cried like he cried i
swear to god and i
i'm what you know yeah because my
because you know like
that generation daddy's little girl like
you know it's this is
funny they thought i was a stoner and i
swear to god
and i started out
it was one it was one time i started it
was like the only time i ever
i ever smoked and i literally it was
like the friends were big stoners and i
was like coughing the whole time i hated
it it was so stupid and
and like my dad cried and it just like
it made me listen yeah libby listened to
him because he was so mad
yeah i think you're right i think it's
more it's more profound when someone
doesn't express that emotion often so if
someone like let's say your mother never
shouts at you like never and then your
mother shouts you one time then i'm like
whoa like mom like did i do something
makes you listen it makes you listen
yeah if you think if you don't do
something often people react to it but
then at the same time like do you want
someone only to show emotion at like one
day in your whole life if you get
married once and it's gonna be one time
your father will cry i mean i prefer it
yeah i mean like that versus once a
month
i don't know i don't know haven't also
have you ever been of a guy who
expressed his emotions that frequently
i don't think i've ever been with a guy
that's expressed his emotions i can't
even compare accurately so this is just
me playing devil's advocate here like i
haven't actually been with a guy that's
so been so expressive of his emotions do
you think you think you reason anyway
haven't been fundamentally not attracted
to it
i don't think you when you're dating
someone i don't think men will show that
side to them so regardless of that guy
is emotional in the future i wouldn't
know from the first day anyway so you'd
have to date this person for quite a
long time to open that kind of stuff
have you ever had a long-term
relationship with someone yeah i've been
in a lot of long-term relationships
maybe two long-term relationships
so in those periods times those guys
show emotions in a way you describe
right now yes and you found attractive
at the time
it's not about finding an attractive
it's about like this person being quite
open with you if you're like in a
partnership with someone long term and
they're comfortable to show their
emotions i think it's very telling of
the kind of relationship that you have
but it does show
it's something that could be a turn off
no i don't think it could be a turn off
no so if someone's going through
something really hard
because they're going through something
really difficult it's not turn off
but also i don't think when she's saying
like showing emotion emotion i don't
think she means like oh like the man's
just like crying i think it's just him
like telling him oh like i really enjoy
doing this with you and made me really
happy like not just negative emotions
it's not always about crying it's also
about happiness just like
acknowledgement of what you guys like
like maybe like did together like oh i
really enjoyed this together like
enjoyment happiness or like it doesn't
always have to be frustration doesn't
mean like extremes you know it can just
be like a subtle yeah this guy's not
going to be mourning once a month this
is going to be like oh i'm happy that
you did this today i'm really proud of
you or like oh this frustrated me
imagine if a guy doesn't tell you he's
frustrated with something like he's just
going to hold on to that and you won't
know and then that's going to lead to
problems in the relationship later
i mean i think it's one thing if a guy
was like oh you hurt my feelings or
versus a guy saying okay you did that
and i won't tolerate it
yeah
like depends one one is one is more
attractive and you know which one it is
you know
oh you hurt me and i won't tolerate it
and you know maybe like i didn't mean to
do it i feel like that kind of would
just kind of like hurt my heart and then
like that
of course like i can open this for you
yeah no worries
i'm sorry guys guys one at a time and
like i feel like like you know that
would be like the kind of turn off for
me because like you know maybe i
like obviously i'd hurt you but it's not
like i purposely did it to hurt you yeah
but then for you just be like oh i don't
tolerate it right but i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm going to disagree with you a
little bit on that one because i've said
this
what you said i agree with you
completely because like girls as funny
as sanjay they just like if you
like did something wrong and a guy is
like it's one thing to do something
wrong and a guy just looks positive but
when a guy is like hey like you know
most girls it's funny so they'd like to
hear that sit down and shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] you know i mean like and they that
[ __ ] is a turnover them
might not be you might not be you but
for some girls would they like that
sturdy when it's kind of like you're go
you're climbing on the man's like you
know you're building up the [ __ ] [ __ ]
and the man just breaks into listen you
need to yeah and then that [ __ ] for most
girls just to turn on
i'm sorry i'm not um
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
okay we got two super chats um in the
time
shane will win stoicism is key to
success as a man women want equality
within the workplace and beyond but then
continually change the rules and expect
men to not adapt to the new rules of
engagement
um just hugh mann a book called
difficult conversation posts that all
conversations even business one have an
underlying emotional undertone not
acknowledging that usually can cause
friction eventually this lady has a
point okay you got
i like that okay guys okay guys remember
all super chats are for another camera
okay
and and um
they're for
headphones too that's the other thing
we're saving for
um okay next question i have
so
i asked the men
if they we lack femininity ladies
do you think that men
laughs
do you think men lack masculinity
nowadays and is that something you look
for
i don't really know like what is
masculinity today
anyways like masculinity i just think
about like
being tall or being built like
athletically that's not even masculinity
like what do you guys define masculinity
as then i can tell you for lacking of it
sorry one more time i got like what do
you guys define masculinity as like
today like i don't even know where to
start um
um i think of just like a traditional
like like when you think of traditional
masculinity like tough
man like maybe even assertiveness yeah
assertive like you know what leadership
i would say is the best way to describe
it so even if you plant like if you have
a date he's gonna plan it he's gonna
take you out he wouldn't let you pay
like that's traditionally masculine i'm
not gonna lie majority of the men i've
been in contact with or dating have been
quite masculine so i wouldn't say like
men are lacking masculinity i do feel
like men make an effort like a conscious
effort to be masculine and i don't think
that many not many women do that anymore
men are more driven to be more masculine
than women are driven to be feminine
okay
okay what do you what do you is that so
would you say that because you have
dated traditionally masculine men yeah
like that's something that's something
you look for a little bit then i guess
so i think you're trying to do something
that's attractive yeah it's probably
it's just kind of funny because that's
kind of the opposite of what you were
saying earlier
i feel like there's something
there's like what you want in an ideal
society and also like what biologically
you're capable of like there's stuff
that are out of my hands there's stuff
like subconsciously my body wants to
have like what i want to have that i
have no choice against right and those
are like traditionally masculine men
traditionally assertive men member
confidence that kind of thing that's
kind of like an evolutionary trait
that's not to do with if i want equality
enough i want to have like
dating equality or like meant to be as
masculine as i want to be meant to be
emotional but obviously biologically
i can i can't go against my biological
energies and things like right right
what about you eileen um i do like um
you know like
hand on the shoulder
no yeah i mean like you know for them to
like lead or what i think it's like
attractive obviously but i mean i don't
need them to do it like all the time
you know like paying for dates that's
attractive but you know i will also like
i would also like be like oh like let me
or probably like secretly do it so that
they don't try to like you know do it
also like oh no let's let's split up and
just be like oh i'm just going to pay
for it
um
yeah
okay so you know it doesn't seem like
that's huge for you and what you look
for would you say your exes have been
more traditionally masculine
my what your exes and like the guy
you're dating now um
no i mean
i feel like you know it's funny because
i wouldn't say like i have a type
just looking back on it i guess i do
because i feel like um maybe i just kind
of like put it in there like i don't
want there to just be one leading person
right clearly is not the problem
huh hides clearly not being the problem
anyways
like i would say like i'm a pretty
not like boss woman or boss what do you
call it like an emancipated woman like
you make your own decisions yeah i'm not
i'd like to be yeah i like to be very
independent i like to not
let the man like only do their thing i
like to be the one to also like chip and
do my part dude that's like your
personality because like here like well
the women on this table we're quite
independent we make our own decisions we
have our own things going on we're quite
career-minded i don't think we're very
representative of all women out there so
different there are women that probably
want different things
as an independent person you kind of
want someone else that's also
self-confident and has their own thing
going for them has their own ambitions
like i'm quite an ambitious woman and i
feel like you guys are as well yeah so i
think that kind of like translates into
what we look for we're looking for men
that also have those traits too yes and
that happens to be masculine as well
yeah is that
an accident is that a coincidence like i
don't know you know because i also like
it when they don't mind me also maybe
leading some of the time yeah and i
think that's where like the 50 50 comes
in mind where like maybe like my type is
someone that likes to leave but also
doesn't mind it when someone else leads
what's an example of a time where you
led in a relationship um
let's see i would say like you know
literally just like planning the whole
day like picking a place to go like how
we will go what time we'll go
i mean it's not even like a big thing i
know i understand so you enjoyed doing
that yeah i like like i mean especially
since i don't know i like picking
out like where to go eat like you're
organized like
thank you i wouldn't say so but i mean
maybe just because i'm
a little or maybe or maybe you're just
with the new all the time so she's maybe
i do like um you know like picking like
i i don't know i think planning dates
are fun so so can i
ask questions yeah
is that expected of you in your
relationship like no i don't think
i don't think anything should be
expected in a relationship i think
like there shouldn't be expectation i
mean i mean okay
don't let me say that actually
okay
i don't think there should be like
i should be planning everything i should
be doing everything it should be i'd
like to have that 50 philly 50 50
balance for everything yeah honestly 50
50 for everything everything was yeah
interesting how do you feel do you have
a back like a follow-up question
i just want to get the opinions i do
feel like
i would like to have some choice in like
what we're doing we're not saying it's
not 100 either way we're just saying so
and so i'm not saying i won't say 50 50
but i would say like in my like day in
life i would like that both people are
having some sort of input like oh like
it's sunny today let's do something
outside and then maybe he chooses a
place that's outside like that kind of
like just having some sort of input
that's not just like okay today we're
going here tomorrow we're going here the
next day we're doing this that you don't
really have much inputs i feel like
modern times like
i feel like we can have that kind of
balance now self pro how do you feel
um
i prefer the guy leads um
but
trying to think yeah i mean i wouldn't
go on a holiday like
i'm kind of in a different situation
just because i know um
i'll be okay
because um
putting the host on the spot right now
like i i know i'm gonna inherit a good
chunk of change so it's like i know he
doesn't really have to provide like that
you know i mean
um but
i mean i prefer like guys that are like
more decisive
the reason why i said questions because
you said you don't mind doing this
whatever you know i just wanted to get
to a point where is it that you don't
mind because you're not expected to do
it it's not you it's not what situation
expected so because it's only once in a
blue moon it's fun to do it sometimes
whereas the guy it's the expectation you
do this do that so i guess the level of
pressure is different so do something
sometimes it's fun something something
do something all the time isn't or may
not be i don't know i personally i like
planning things sometimes like
um i feel like trips is fun to plan like
i think i i i'd rather take leads when
we planned like a trip if you're going
abroad i would like to be more in
control because i kind of have more i
don't know i feel like i'm more
experienced in like traveling and things
like that like do what you're good at i
would technique there yeah what about
what do you feel like about the
stereotype where women like you know
when you have the um when you like move
into your house and stuff like that how
do you feel about the stereotype being
like women are like the decorators like
you know me like putting out together
but like
like
we are i just generally want to know
about this i just really want to know
about it i feel like i should take leave
because i feel like i've seen men's
interior design if you go into any guy's
room
i'm sorry like they've got the basics
going but a lot of men don't really pay
attention to design the reason
the reason why i asked this year is
because like unless it's an interior
designer
when like the thing is don't even wrong
it like your imaginations when it comes
to decorating the colors to stuff like
that like i take your hats off you're
like yeah you got it yeah but it's just
the man's gotta put up with that like
you got your man working all the time
moving the couch thirty centimeters to
the left and then fifteen back like it's
it's but like at the end of the day like
the man's gonna be looking
[Music]
yeah at the end of the day like you're
both going to be sharing that space i
feel like if he doesn't want something
there like you can talk about it but i
think majority of the time a woman has a
really good intuition for design yeah
but when we talk about it we sleep on
the couch that's
that's the problem yeah because the
guy's designer but yeah we have the tv
on the floor with like just one chair
and like his ps5 what's wrong with that
that's like this
i kind of got a thing for cheap guys
though so there's something about it
there's something about it
an empty apartment where i'm like you
hate spending money don't you me too
you know what if you're like why don't i
send super chats
you know what it was
what i've um come to find out um
recently actually um there was i think
who was it um i think it was like elon
musk well one of like one of the
richest guys richest guys right what
they have said was like
when up when a guy or or any person
right that has like when you don't have
like a clean room like like a clean
freaking like
the person that's like really the one
that be making the good box and like you
know in the future is the person with
the mess room because they keep in like
open mind about like they keep you just
like
i don't know kind of like he what's the
hippie temple like that like oh you just
keep it like organized
bass yeah basically that yeah right
there because there's a lot of like
theories like maths and algorithms like
people that organize like say libraries
that organize message actually better
than organizing something so let's say
you have the most commonly read books
put them on the shelf to organize them
back
actually waste time because you're
hiding the most commonly read books so
it's kind of better to have that
organized mess
just there access
the people that read those books the
most can have access to describe my room
that way
i would definitely describe my own
organized mess is different from like
like unhygienic though yeah let's draw
that line so i
my bathroom is sparkly clean but like oh
clothes are on the you know the special
chair
there's always that one chair one [ __ ]
always has to hold it
all the leggings and my sweatpants and
my sweatshirts i wear all the time
okay
i have a question um for the women
do you guys find it attractive do you
guys find it attractive when men know
how to do like like when they're handy
and can do like traditional 100 percent
120 200 percent that's myself 300
builders this one take him into my house
if you can if you can build me a house
let's get married like if you can build
a house
at me
um
okay you know she is shocking
hey i can hold it all like that and then
some see that way no because that is so
attractive um we can either of you can't
wait wait can can either of you build a
house
for no no no no no i've been so
just yes or no just yes or no so you can
build up could you build a house don't
get married are you guys do you want to
listen
to
me
okay
obviously when i was when i was
obviously when my parents were it was a
little bit a different time same way for
you and for everyone else but for me
when i was still raised i was still
raised under the like because obviously
my family luckily i was fortunate enough
to have a lumberjack business whether
you know your cut wood planks and all
that stuff they have a fishing business
they have mechanic businesses for that
so i was always raised around being like
the handiest kind of thing
all the you know everything that you
need to be basically to be a man this
one is so attractive now
it's not even no it's not it's not going
down the words got you baby
that's not even but that's the type of
stuff that i was brought up to from a
very young age and when i moved here
my
mentality was i got to go into like the
construction business so when i did high
squad construction i did all the like do
you do you think that's because you're
from you're from lithuania yeah so do
you think it's about to bring back the
the background checks no no
it's more traditional there isn't that
would you say yes yes absolutely uh like
men are generally in lithuania mainly
uh generally if you don't if you have
your own business okay it's great like
you can be whatever you want to be in
that in that business you pay your own
salary but if you don't most men drift
towards um obviously construction uh a
good road works it's very very well paid
there um just any sort of like a general
hands-on hands-on work yeah lumberjack
is another very good one especially in
the villages and stuff i don't know
about you guys i think like trades it's
very attractive to me very attractive it
shows like discipline yeah someone
that's working hard yeah yeah you're
working hard i don't care what you're
doing i
i agree i respect it like you don't have
to have a degree like if you're working
hard and you have a skill that you're
good at and you're actually good at it
like you've mastered
something yeah so attractive that's what
i always say if i had to give dating
advice to guys like let her see
something you're good at yeah because
please yes please but the thing is the
term the term mastering your skills is
taken like out of context because
in in life right no matter how good you
are or something that's all in that area
there's always something you can
good at improve no yeah it's one thing
to say you're good at it but like
mastering i feel like it's taken out of
context because
every day like you learn something no
matter how good you are you could be
like the greatest maybe like someone
that's like not i mean i guess like
always trying to improve themselves
always trying to improve what they
already know
you know it's better than average like
above averaging this one thing and you
should know that he's invested time to
learning this thing yeah it doesn't have
like it doesn't really matter what it is
if you dedicate time to something you're
going to be good at it and better than
average and i really respect that
because you've learned that yourself so
guys
go ahead go ahead
would you date a plasterer or a plumber
120 yeah okay okay
no one ever knows but they actually
earned the most money
electricians are you crazy
i kind of i have a thing for trades guys
i don't know what it is
[Applause]
we're losing composure
okay
now now question for the man is it
attractive to you if a woman can like
cook and clean
and like like do the traditionally
feminine things traditionally
yes but not so much now because
obviously i feel i feel like personally
i'll be i'll be mutualistic i feel like
everyone at a certain age should learn
how to cook like cook
just do the basics like
take care of yourself exactly because
yeah look
um i was raised in a house so my um dad
passed away before i was born so i was
raised in a house of women right so i
was always raised up of like respecting
women you know respecting their choice
all that stuff i've learned how to cook
clean do the
feminine stuff like all the female stuff
from very young so i feel like i'm gonna
be mutual in this i'm not gonna you know
say yes or no but like i feel like
everyone at a certain stage in their
life to be like like the most basic
thing is like cooking like you never
know you might be living by yourself for
for years and years how are you going to
survive without knowing the best thing
of cooking an egg you know it's just
like if you don't know how to take care
of yourself like
you shouldn't be dating you'll be
working on yourself
like go read the book
clothes learn how to clean your room
yeah could i ask a follow-up question
so like you like said oh like is it
attractive when women have like those
feminine qualities but also okay is it
attractive when women are you know that
independent can take care of herself
like doesn't need no doesn't mean anyone
but with you know wouldn't mind being
with another person i feel like i feel
like with the with the whole like
oh i'm an independent like at a certain
age like when you're young and you're
like okay you've got your business going
you're working hard and you're making
your own money you're you've really
earned as an independent woman and i i
respect that you do your own thing you
know you go to work nine to five
whatever you do and you come back home
you pay the bills when you take care of
your own right i respect that right but
then at a certain age every woman i feel
like they're gonna come to a time where
it's like it's honestly i need a man but
like i just i would rather you know not
be alone type thing
right so it's like it is attractive to a
certain extent but like when they start
going with like nah nah it's one of
those things where it's like you got to
be open to let someone help you yeah
like yeah you just like like you can be
independent i respect yeah but you've
got to be always open to be like listen
like because you will need something
yeah you know you might be good at old
like
abcd and efg and then the rest you will
need someone to help you but you won't
accept the help because in your mind
you're an independent woman so you don't
mind the independence but you would like
them to accept the help if you were
offering it probably yeah
i'll tell you about that yeah yeah
so i'm going to go back a couple of
questions and then come at you in a
minute okay so the question you walks is
if men find it attractive if women can
cook and what have you
so i find it i find it quite interesting
that
you that you said that
you were saying like yeah when you were
to cook
and you said everyone should cook as
well but when we asked questions about
should men be able to be
masculine in terms of building things it
was like yes they should be so my my my
takeaway from that is that you prefer
men to keep those traditional
masculine type roles but wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait time
can you land when it came to the flip
side yeah you weren't you didn't
see it in the same so the same
the same energy no i didn't came to the
women i didn't say i love femininity
like 100 like i said before that i
believe that women should be a bit more
like embrace terminating more so i'm all
for femininity and masculinity
so when we came to men doing things it
was [ __ ] years attractive is sex yeah or
120 but if but you when it came to women
cooking it was that what everyone should
cook no because cooking is different
like skills but yeah because building a
house is something you don't do like all
the time cooking is something you do
like three times a day so if you can't
cook when you've been doing it three
times a day like your whole life then
like you can't actually live by yourself
you can't be autonomous but building a
house is not something you have in your
daily routine so that's why i wouldn't
say it's like a necessity to do would
you say it was back to traditional
traditional
gender roles traditional gender roles
that men can boo use their hands and
we're going to be in the kitchen i think
it's traditionally masculine i think
that is attractive in itself but i don't
think that takes away from the fact that
everyone should know how to cook and
clean because cooking and cleaning is
something that everyone requires in
their day-to-day life you're missing the
point i'm making i'm not saying that you
shouldn't do it but the energy you gave
when you would talk about how men should
be when christian was asked what should
man be mexican can build and stuff it
was like [ __ ] yeah energy was there but
it wasn't the same energy when it came
to cooking it was like war let's do
things equally because it wasn't like
mensch you didn't say you didn't say oh
everyone should go to when they would be
sure to put houses it was yes men that's
eternal for me it's a question where
it's different the question is always
attractive if a man can build a house he
didn't ask if the question was is
attractive a woman can build a house
right that's right one can build a house
um
my pants will drop so far would be
halfway through
a woman
i'm sorry yeah like if a woman can do
something as well like it's just as
impressive as a man can do it i'm just
saying like because my sexuality is
towards men i'm heterosexual i like men
then obviously it's attracted to me if a
man can build a house because if i won't
keep the house great we can be best
friends but like it's different so my
takeaway is that
equality you don't want equality it's
not to do with equality i think you're
missing the point if it was equal you
would have the equal injury but if you
would have said you would have said
they're different tasks so like eating
and cooking for yourself you require at
least three times a day
like living by yourself so if i want to
date someone that can live autonomously
by themselves they should know how to
cook minimum but building a house that's
something that's on top that's an extra
quality that someone has acquired and
learnt to do that's outside the normal
level of what normal people do so like
cooking everyone should know how to do
so i expect that but when someone can
build a house it's like oh i didn't
expect that that you can do that that's
amazing you have this extra skill that
you have acquired in your own time
that's two different things i think it
is typically masculine but that he can
do that is just just unlike a cherry on
the top like someone has a quieter skill
it can be anything doesn't have to be
building a house per se but like if
someone's made the effort to acquire
something and master something is really
attractive so it could be a language it
could be another skill but i'm just
saying that a house is like very
impressive because i can't i can't do
that and i don't know anyone that can so
when someone says that i'm like wow
so bring house isn't really an
additional skill it's something you do
you don't want to say there's no one no
one works uh no one's uh no one
generally generally speaking no one's a
a nurse a male or nurse and then
everybody on the side builds houses at
the same time yeah you're a house
builder that's why i'd be shocked when
they can do it you know so you did if
someone was a house he's a he's a
builder by trade but what point should i
make his
level a level of energy was different
you you didn't say oh it would be great
if women could do it as well but when it
came to cooking it was like a woman a
mention to do as well as a woman
cooking is not like a genitive like
cooking has nothing to do with why is
building gender defined i even define it
as a gender question where you answered
it you defined it as gender no the
question was do you find it attractive
when men build houses the question to us
was is it attractive women can cook and
your answer do you answer the saying
that everyone should cook yeah because
everyone should be able to cook but why
is there
it would be able to build a house
because you all live in houses right no
one asked that question i think it would
be great if anyone could build houses no
but the question was is it attractive
and men do it and you didn't say you
didn't try to say it
but did it too but
when women cook i'm
i hear what you're saying i'm hearing
you saying that because i'm attracted to
men obviously i'm attracted to when they
do things and that men are doing those
things if you say like oh women are
doing this traits great but like i'm not
attracted to them sexually because
they're doing those traits because i'm
attracted to men so regardless if a
woman can cook or if she can build a
house i'm more attracted to men that
build a house and can cook because i'm
attracted to men period so that i think
i think the point is like he's saying
you expect one from one gender and you
don't expect one from the other and the
reason is like because people order
takeout people you have no you don't
have to order your friends you can do a
meal and building a house
maybe not say build a house but like fix
fix something like i personally i can't
fix that cabinet right there and if
anyone knows how to like you baby girl
you need a drill don't you i don't have
any tools now she doesn't just ask me to
bring the tools don't worry i got you i
found my drill don't worry i got it no
but i think again i think the point he's
making is one is it's like it's just
kind of the world we live in where men
are expected to do things and like women
aren't and it's almost insulting
you can choose there's no there is no
obligation you're saying
you're saying you can't you haven't seen
you haven't said you've used the words
exactly but you're saying it
we're obligated to be traditional men
we're obligated to do no one's overly
things no one's obligated but it's just
my friend i think she's she's saying
it's more attractive she doesn't say
more sexually yeah that do those things
beyond what's normal yeah beyond the
average they're right went beyond the
normal person they're like i'm gonna
learn this thing that no one else is
doing so you know
yeah yeah you know what it's reminds me
this is this is that whole ammo i'm a
woman thing where it's like oh darling
can you open my like the jar of
mayonnaise or something like that that's
just like
oh i can't do it you pass it on and he's
like oh and then he's like all right
and you're looking at him differently
you know i mean that's that's what
that's that's the type of what i'm
getting from that
i don't know i feel like
i got it
i feel like that wasn't what you said
okay change to change the topic can you
cook yes
like actually yeah like actually can you
cook
no actually don't answer that i know i
don't answer that can you i know i just
peanut cooking salmon on our stories
selfless to say right like if you see
right let's say example um you can if
ever if someone in the room can cook
right yes and let's say for example you
meet someone right like you meet another
person right and then
they bring your like you've dated them
for like x amount of time right not
enough to bring him to bring you over to
his right and you trust him enough to go
right and then you would like and
instead of like would he be more
attractive yeah if he's like listen
we're not going to go out we're going to
come back to my house and i'm going to
make you dinner like would you find out
more or more more attractive than a man
if he was like listen we're not gonna
we're going to skip the movies we're
going to skip whatever we was going to
do we're going to come back to my place
we're going to have some wine i'm going
to i'm going to i'm as a man i'm going
to cook i think that's quite attractive
i think i'm a big foodie and i think
that's quite attractive when someone
says is the food good yeah
well i'm not exactly going to all the
popeye's chicken i'm
you know regardless like whether it's
good or not i think it's really
attractive because like it kind of shows
like the initiative yeah initiative the
effort is put in and you're like you're
trying to like kind of kind of
personalize someone yeah and you're like
hey like let's just have a night like by
ourselves without like you know yeah i
think it's kind of romantic actually
yeah but i think that
i mean the cooking thing i feel like
this cooking idea like oh like oh can i
cook can the woman do this so can a man
cook it's really annoying because
cooking isn't that hard
like i don't know what like most people
are cooking but i don't feel like the
general skills required to cook is very
difficult like baby cooking hopes and
dreams
that's what they'd be quick yeah like if
you want to put like a simple pasta like
you just got to put the kettle on put
the pot on the stove and put the pasta
in there and wait 10 minutes like you
don't really have to do that much like
when people say they can't cook it's
like you're going out of your way not to
learn like your mom was like oh let me
show you well i know but some people
just get taken out
some guys like like my dad okay like if
he was single okay he would never learn
how to cook because he works 80 hours a
week if you're working at eight hours a
week i do not expect you to cook because
cooking takes time well yeah but that's
that's what i'm saying like like it
doesn't because you're saying it just to
be alive you have to cook but i'm saying
some people it doesn't fit in their
lifestyle they just order knowing how to
use certain things i feel like knowing
how to use a pan i haven't used like
knowing how to use an oven like to put
like a micro like a meal and
it's pretty basic knowledge like i feel
like it wouldn't take you that long to
figure out and when someone says they
can't do that it's kind of like
well you can like spend five minutes and
work it out and you you could but the
thing is like if if we're if we're
talking about cooking right like the way
the way i take cooking right is like
look it's one thing to like when you
know what
cooking for me uh like i've i've been
i've been i've learned how to cook like
from a very young age right but the
thing is like
for cooking for me is like making
something out of nothing so like you
take the most basic ingredients take the
most basic spices and you make something
right ready to eat meals or something
that you stick in the microwave for five
minutes is not considered cooking to me
cooking to me something like if i was to
make a pizza i will not go and buy
pre-made dough i will make the dough
myself that's cooking you know what i
mean that's cooking okay i see what you
mean but like the skills required to
make a doll isn't that difficult like
you just need to weigh some like some
like flour okay okay
maybe something
how do you make dough how do you make
those yeah like flour okay water yeast
oil salt maybe pepper if you want to
have some spices in there okay you leave
it for a while to like grow okay and
then you put it out and then you roll it
out but i just feel like most of these
things come with easy eggs but you're
pretty much spot on like you have eggs
and pizza though
a little bit
so like i feel like those skills
required aren't that difficult like
modern society you can google something
it'll take you like five minutes to
figure out like to weigh something to
put it in the oven i like the skills
required i feel like everyone should be
able to figure that out like basic like
google stuff like that and speaking of
and speaking of like that yeah like
cooking in in itself nowadays right i
feel like the reason the reason why i
feel like everyone should be able to
cook is beautiful like the
back back like 30 40 when internet
wasn't a thing they really needed to use
the cook recipe book and most people
saying like women should have a cookbook
you don't have to have a cook but the
internet is limitless it's free it's
it's there for you to find out if you
want to know how to if you want if you
want to know how to cook a simple thing
as lasagna it's go on google how to cook
it and i also think like it's a sign of
like if you don't have a cookie like
you're not a foodie and i'm a big food
product i love food and if you're saying
to me like you don't know how to make a
basic lasagna or basic pasta like it's
just telling me that you don't enjoy the
food like i know you go home and you eat
dry rice
i just i think i just i really i really
think the point is you expect one thing
from men and you don't expect it like
from women i expect that from both
genders that we're both not no no i know
but yeah it's the i don't expect us both
to not build a house i don't expect both
of us to have like a really rare skill
right
that's what like okay i'll give you so
i'll give you a small scenario right
your man works let's say you're in a
relationship yeah your mom works let's
say like
50 hours a week right which is which is
pretty decent so i work in construction
right
he expects
he doesn't expect but like it should it
shouldn't be said but like
a hot meal at the end of the day he
wants to come back the last thing he
wants to do is come back home uh make
food take a shower what he wants to come
to come back to you is you know come
back to you give you a kiss on a cheek
i'm going to take a shower no i
completely i completely agree i was in a
relationship where the person was
learning a lot more than me and i didn't
work
and i was like okay then i'm gonna cook
like you're not gonna come home and have
to cook after all that whole like whole
day of work like if you're earning for
both of us then i'm gonna cook for both
of us like you gotta do what you're good
at and do what now bring what you can
bring to the table like just make like
just be fair like i don't understand
like why people want to get into
relationships that like unfair for them
like i don't understand like why would
you why would you seek that like for men
too like why would you seek a woman that
doesn't want to bring anything to your
relationship i think that's like for
both people to look at not just men or
women i feel like both should look at
like are they bringing anything
do you enjoy do you value them like i
feel like both people are responsible
for finding that stuff like you can't
just like blame women like oh like she
doesn't want to do this this and this
but like you let her because you
continue to
i don't know like do you have that same
energy for men or for women that allow
like men to do certain things yeah like
if the woman is like earning her money
and she's doing her thing she's working
hard and it may be more than the man
then like maybe the man should stay at
home and cook them and help the
relationship and help things more easier
like run the household it's not i'm
sorry that's not enough in some cases
but like no not in a lot of men that's
not us that's not a nature like for
example she asked a very good question
from
me i think it was last podcast right she
was like
i think it was like um something about
them like the money-wise like would you
be uh
a stay-at-home husband or if you're if
so if your wife or partner earns more
than you and she asks you to be a
stay-al-husband like basically she's a
breadwinner yeah would you want to be
that right absolutely not i would say no
absolutely no purely for the fact that
like i like making my own money because
that money is my money it's not it's not
hers if i ask if i ask my woman to just
continuously oh stay at home
i'm gonna you know give you like an
allowance that just makes me feel like
i'm some you know i can't take care of
myself i would i like making my own
money i can understand that like in the
same way you don't want to be that role
like i really look forward to being like
a stay-at-home mom like i look forward
to having a kid and staying home with my
kid and spending time with my kid and
like doing that having that experience
of them growing up and being at home i
was like maybe guys are just built
different and just one different it's
like interesting because i feel like
what you say you want and what you
actually want are like so different
like
like i i like it just seems like you
kind of want the traditionally masculine
guy but you're still pushing for men to
be feminine when you say what you want
like emotionally available but i just i
have a feeling that that would turn you
off i feel like it's not mutually
exclusive i feel like i'm probably
looking for something that's probably
unideal probably unrealistic right i
will say that now like i'm looking for
someone that can be masculine and
emotional at the same time which is
probably really hard to ask
i just don't think that's real maybe
like not really
you know
it may be unrealistic to ask for but
like i kind of it would be interesting
if that was around like an interesting
type of relationship that could offer
both masculinity and both well that's
the emotional issue it's like a guy
asking you to be masculine and feminine
yeah but i think women do have that kind
of range like women can be
i'm not saying that when men ask for
that i'm just saying that women have
that range you're asking for a man
you're asking for a man to be messy and
effeminate i'm not asking for a
masculine feminine masculinity
those were your words no no
i said masculine and emotional you said
masculine
or feminine i don't i don't i can't
clearly remember where are you going
but yeah i think yeah pearl's probably
right with the unrealistic aspect i feel
like i expect like a really like ideal
world as just not the reality but like
isn't it nice to expect things i feel
like having expectations is nice and
hopes is like nice i feel like you
shouldn't be so nihilistic about things
that you guys expect traits in women
that probably aren't realistic like
maybe you expect i don't think men do
i'm gonna be honest i don't i think
people stand as like all standards are
like met it's like it's like literally
like don't be fat
um
like don't be fat be attractive um be
nice to me and like act like you like me
but like don't you think it's sad that
like men don't care if you're
intelligent
like sometimes they want someone smart
raising the kids
they're not someone intellectually i
don't like
i don't think i think a lot of times
when girls say intelligence they kind of
mean a headache and they like to argue
no i'm sorry
i agree with that one i'm saying you can
disagree with me but like personally
myself i don't know if you agree with
this but i find intelligent sexy like if
a woman if a woman knows her [ __ ]
no
what you're confusing is that what paul
said he's been being intelligent and
being argumentative no no i'm not
confusing those i'm confused like okay
like a woman that's academically smart
and the woman that's not academically
well i think because what would have
meant
i think because like some of the dumbest
people i know are academically smart
no i swear to god no because like they
think they're so like they're so
intellectual but they have no common
sense i do that's true
like street smarts that's what it is no
people that are really like well
educated like that do phds tend to work
people with phds
no no you have them arguing of men or
men and women or women like that's the
type of idiots you have in
academia sorry just witness what we're
trying to do
what
no i wasn't talking about that i was
talking about the trans like college
thing yeah but like that's what i mean
like some of the smart like the smartest
people have no common sense and just
like to argue yeah and i think that's
what like like arguments tonight just
like yeah but it's not like what a man
like do you think like men are attracted
to it like actual intelligence and women
like women that are academically smart
like women that like i don't know that
like to have intellectual conversations
so
i think i think mentioned hey i was
talking to someone else might be enough
conversation but
there are a couple of things that work
well in relationships and especially if
you're wearing children as well so
dual parent household
households children have better life
outcomes
when your partner the mother is uh
highly intelligent the children
therefore put not normally because she
imparts is only the woman's job to
impart wisdom and into the children so
they feel like if she's intelligent then
the children will be intelligent so the
answer should answer your question is no
men not men are not men are attractive
to women that are intelligent whoever
what what normally comes with women that
that can be intelligent or especially
women or bosses and
what have you have a have
personality traits
that surpass like not that attractive
not attractive exactly so that's why i
can understand that so we can often get
that confused yes i'm intelligent but
you don't need to be discussing
intelligent and no stuff
so it's a bit like a
like who is leading this household
it's because there's a difference
there's a difference between being
intelligent and being disagreeable
because the trait disagreeable it's um
like i'll give you an example i i was
never really picked for captain
positions yeah because i'm i'm an
agreeable person like if i take a
personality test i'm at 70th percentile
in agreeableness so that means like if i
hired someone i would have a really hard
time firing them
it's going to be difficult yeah and fire
them
let the weak ones go but but what i'm
saying is like is is for someone that's
disagreeable they're like no quick i'm
gonna do it like that's that's the
decision i'm making and disagreeable
people make better bosses
and so and so because they're quick with
decisions
and they're not afraid to tell you how
it is where agreeable people like tend
to sugarcoat it they're a little bit
nicer and so men are more attracted to
agreeable women that are just nice and
want to follow i don't know go to work
and come home after and everything
everything every decision made has to be
discussion
i'll come home and say or win whatever
we're doing we're going to buy a new
house we're going to go on holiday
whatever you
know everything needs to be a 20-minute
discussion of the pros and cons of order
ins and outs what we're doing it's just
we're doing this let's go
but women who were disagreeable and
sometimes bosses and very highly
intelligent want to discuss everything
and there's not there's not always a
need it's it's tiring it's draining to
have to always
lay out every single step so what you're
saying is like the typical intelligent
woman is not really attractive to men no
no i said sometimes what i said is i
didn't say i said i said men are
attracted to intelligence because we
know
those of us the kind of men you want to
be with not all of us but kind of men
you want to be with will find that
attractive but what a lot of women
confuse and conflate has been
intelligent and been disagreeable and
the two things are different what you
find is a lot of telling women are
disagreeable and that's not good so a
lot of intelligent women are
disagreeable is like the general
consensus here
and because of that reason
generally men won't find intelligent
women attractive it's kind of the
correlation i'm trying i would guess
that it's more like the intelligent
women that tend to make a lot of money
that's what i would say because everyone
that earns a lot of money doesn't really
need to take [ __ ] from anyone so she
probably wouldn't compromise no no i
think no no it's it's again disagreeable
people make better bosses
so so if you wanna if you wanna make a
ton of money like the only way to make a
ton of money is to be able to hire
people like even even now like with this
channel like i've just started bringing
other people on and i'm telling you like
like this is something that i'm really
working to get better at because it
doesn't come naturally to me like
leading people bossing them around
telling them what to do i just want to
be like oh do whatever you want you know
yeah it's it doesn't come naturally like
assertiveness yeah
right like delegation right right right
so so women that are disagreeable aren't
attractive to men and that's who makes
the most money because you make the most
money and hiring people so we see a
combination with high earning women and
disagreeableness yes and men not
following them attractive that's what
we're doing here but if you have an
intelligent like mother like like you
i'm sure you can think of some woman in
your family who didn't make a lot of
money but is one of the smartest people
you know yeah yeah of course right of
course they've got their own
organization they can run a whole
household they've got the whole thing
going i respect that 100 percent i don't
know your cultural background but my
prayer my caption is caribbean and mum
and my mom would say one thing you
should just say she's a lot of these old
caribbean sayings but one she thinks you
said all the time is two bulls can't
rule one pen
okay it's like too many chefs will spill
them off kind of thing so one of you can
you both can't be the boss boss one of
has to submit you can't be an officer
disagree if you or if you're a
disagreeable person then it's not going
to work in a relationship one of you has
got to do to leave okay
both can't be going head-on all the time
i do i do think like this that needs to
be some sort of balance i did grow up in
like a quite christian household and i
do think that that kind of follows like
someone's going to be the head of the
household and that's normally like the
file to figure the male figure in the
house someone's making the leading
decisions i do think that it's important
that there's always someone you can go
to that has a decisive answer and can
lead but i just i just i do feel like
sometimes
the intelligence of the woman is wasted
sometimes because that role is kind of
normally generally pushed through just
because just because the lead the man is
a lead and he's making a decision
doesn't mean that your your input is not
important i think a lot of times when
people go here submissive they think
that oh i have to shut up i can't say a
word i've gotta just listen you know
what i didn't even think about that but
it's just me you have a captain of an
airplane you have a captain in the boat
yeah a vice guy you have a president in
the country of a prime minister country
they all have advisers to give
information and provide information it's
him it's within that leader that captain
that president
to absorb information and make a
decision based on what information is
brought and sort of impress on what the
experts saying so just because he's a
lead doesn't mean your voice isn't that
the input isn't there but what we're
saying is stop don't there's no need to
be sometimes decisions you made
don't i don't have to spend i don't want
to have to every time this is made i
have to explain to you the steps the
process
with the program sorry but you know what
he said sometimes uh like the world
leaders right sometimes they they're
just a face it's uh in some cases
yeah the advisors are the ones that
sometimes i'll be making the big like
decisions because the advisors is more
than one person in a room talking about
it and then again then when the lead the
actual world leader which is the face of
the country
between these two
yeah
options
that's quite interesting i didn't think
of it like that way but i do think yeah
like
circle back to the beginning of this
question is like do men like intelligent
women it's like what is like what was
your final answer on that is that like
is that yeah
so it was yes but we don't like we don't
like disagreeable women we don't like
disabilities okay men don't like
disagree about women yeah there's one
thing you take away from that that's one
thing you should learn okay interesting
interesting i'm going to read some super
chats real quick yes um
sentience
this is you are i gave you a wrench okay
so you are a moderator you can kick
people out
you can do you can do whatever you want
okay okay um okay so uh fifty dollars
from sentience you can't you have a
woman who can't define masculinity yet
they throw around propaganda like toxic
masculinity how can you know what's the
toxic side of masculinity when you don't
even know what it is so stunning and
brave empowered women these days
interesting interesting
um okay next one
hold on another one from sentience
modern women want to be
sahm what does that mean
hm
sam
after after going through the carousel
if a man if the man you would choose to
be sahm for why would he choose your
roast beef sandwich after the emotional
after after the emotional physical
trauma when he can get a traditional
woman make it make sense
amen
dana
these there are societies where men and
women are side by side in all sectors
soldiers construction medical and home
rows it's definitely societal norms okay
guys um oh stay at home mom that's what
that stands for um also guys thank you
so much for the super chats like i
really appreciate it you guys are
helping me get a new camera in here i'm
really hoping to get it in a couple
weeks so again um
every super chat helps and if you also
want to support the channel um buy one
of the meal plans it'll help you lose
weight
yeah
and i get and i get
whoever is from london
let us know
we need people here
anyone from london that knows any trades
let us know
you got one right here oh yeah that is
true
what's your socials
what do you think would you would you
would you would you date her
[Music]
up just like up and down
up and down i mean
[Laughter]
live on the pre-game
i mean you did say you wanted a segment
about blind dates so you know i really
do um interesting interesting concept
okay um also guys
oh wow actually sorry my friends from
lithuania are tuning into this
yeah also guys
we're we're looking for people to host
segments on the show um basically like
like you would
um so if you're interested um send me an
email at justpearlythings gmail.com you
have to be in london so
uh london or just you can be willing to
make a trip
yeah
i mean you have to be able to do it like
like it's gonna be on a schedule so
yeah anyways like semi often where you
could work it out
oh she left
she had to go i don't know
no not even a goodbye
your brand new mic yeah
um
okay sorry
what was i gonna ask i think i went
through most of my questions so
actually final question of the night
what
would you like in a partner moving
forward like in 2022
authenticity like authenticity
authenticity yeah
um what does that mean it's very vague
what does that mean like you know like i
feel like in modern society i know it's
difficult because everyone has so many
different expectations like someone that
can be
their own like just their own
personality and have their own decisions
their own opinions regardless of what
other people are saying like right now
there's a lot of culture like very
conformity like everyone wants to agree
with everything everyone's have the same
opinion as everybody else thinks someone
that can have their own opinions and be
very authentic to their own culture
their own background so their race is
also very interesting to me can i can i
say something to you yes
and
so what i've noticed i'm the building of
you guys right and what i've noticed is
that especially with women
specifically is that
what you say besides we have this way
first okay as humans right we're more
alike than we are different okay that's
why social sciences exist
that's why you can group people together
and have a good that's why personal like
traits exist and testimony because you
can say well if you think this way these
groups of people will behave this way
right so keep that in mind but what i've
noticed is
is that women like to think they're more
individual than they are
the same as everybody else okay what
makes you the same as everybody else
that you all think you're individual
okay does that make sense yeah you get
that right yeah you always say oh i'm
independent i'm different to this i'm
not the norm i'm special
i'm authentic i think we're differently
but the fact you're saying that makes it
all the same as everybody else because
all women say those sort of things so i
found a very interesting that you see
you mentioned authenticity and that
they're not yours they're in a
relationship everybody's saying we're
trying to say all we're pretty much all
the same and because you say that you
know how we're all the same isn't it
refreshing when someone isn't no but
we're not dick we're not we are the same
point we're not different we're all
humans but i feel like someone can be
very in touch with like where they're
from their own culture i think people
are so different yeah
yeah like i think more people are the
same than we are different i feel like
people play how do you do the same what
are you like what are you talking about
so
like that could mean so many things
so it's getting hot because if we if
we're if we were all six billion people
that were all individual all thought
differently or acted differently then
things like social science could never
exist because how can you how could you
group people how could you have an idea
of what someone's going through and how
to get act and print and
perceive what the next steps are if
everybody was individual how can
criminal investigators know how a serial
killer thinks if everybody thinks
different there are traits that we all
possess right
there's like two percent of the
population like it's a very rare
personality type that's just another
example social sciences
we have these social scientists because
like what's your point it exists
my point is that we are more the same
that we are different so
is there a problem that i'm attracted to
authenticity i'm saying
is it unrealistic for me to ask for that
100 percent
because we're more we're more relaxed
than we are different
you know how we're like arguing right
now that just shows our differences and
i feel like it's like a good example of
how you can be authentic and how you can
have your own appearance i just don't
understand okay sorry i don't understand
hold on i need you both
for a second okay so
when you say authentic do you you just
mean like like being yourself right
being yourself being like open and like
no one's connected with like your
background
okay i understand no no no yeah no yeah
oh no yeah come back to you okay so what
what's your like what's your caveat with
that because we're all the same like i
just don't think i understand so my
point is this to be you well maybe maybe
i've interpreted it wrong so you can
correct me okay so my understanding is
if you're authentic right
in towards yours the way you're
describing it is that
you are different but you think you're
not
and what i'm trying to say is that no
he's not special to everybody else he's
just the same as everybody else because
we're all the same okay well you
interpreted authenticity wrong i meant
more so he's in connect with like let's
say you're from the caribbean for
example and he owns that he's from the
caribbean he owns he's from this culture
he has his background he owns that he
doesn't try to be anybody else
it's more like honesty almost yeah like
just accepting where you're from and
like what your traits are and like being
open to expressing things not trying to
be i'm completely different okay i'll
give you i know what she's talking about
i'll give you an example like
there there are certain guys that like
you go on a date with them and you can
tell they're trying to be like the alpha
or the superman like when they're just
naturally not like they're just not them
it's just not them and so it's like like
yeah okay like uh there's some general
patterns with humans but there's so much
like disparity between people like
she's right like you guys
yeah like we're arguing right now so
they're all different or even even if i
talk to someone i can gauge like what
am i saying if i talk to someone
i can gauge like what socioeconomic
status someone is from just like talking
to someone i can gauge if they're more
liberal or more conservative i can gauge
if they're more fun or they're more like
exactly and it's like you should own and
so like if a boring guy is trying to be
fun it's inauthentic because he's boring
and he's like pretending to be fun
if that's what you meant then i i
apologize i misunderstood what you were
saying i think i think you're
misunderstood but i do think like i feel
like you would probably find that
attractive too someone could own let's
say you're a liberal person like just
own that if you're conservative owns
that you're conservative yeah like even
me when i first met you i was like look
like i'm republican i can respect that
because you're owning it you're not like
i'm gonna hide this view that i have i'm
trying to manipulate people it was crazy
i found like even when i say i'm like
conservative or whatever like liberals
don't care as long as you're up front
or they pretend they care okay they'll
go online and type away but if i'm in
person they'll say hi to me
yeah like just owen like even like
sometimes i think a lot of people
especially from like poc backgrounds
they don't really own the cultures that
they're from and i feel like it's a
shame like i feel like you should really
like you know own like okay i'm from the
caribbean i'm from this place like just
own your stuff you know i don't own any
like i just i'm american
i think america america is a different
place america's have no culture yeah
america we don't even have a language my
america is kind of like all the same
like okay number one number one number
one
what's the national language of america
english
american don't try it don't try to claim
it
this is english
i just mean like i wouldn't care if
someone
like that to me wouldn't matter
because even like my grandma's
great-grandma's from lithuania i know
you're told
culture cool
if i don't know anything about them
yeah i know that's what what was the
question again sorry like what do you
find attractive like yeah what do you
find attractive
no no what was the what was that what
was the actual question because i was
like
oh yeah i forgot yes
for me sorry so it's not like a really
like
uh
game changer thing but like i feel like
what uh like a long uh term relationship
uh
lacks and i feel like this needs to be
like talked about as being spontaneous
with your partner because i've keep
coming back to the whole like oh that
when you first meet somebody is the the
honeymoon stage three to four months is
the golden numbers right after that it's
about communication about that but what
people most forget is okay you can talk
about a problem like a
house move something happens your
parents are something right something
but you can always talk about it but
that's one part
another thing what most people forget is
that being spontaneous it's like
surprising like keeping your partner on
your toes like you're coming back home
and let's say you finish work late last
thing you want to do is you know come
back and argue or you know cook food or
something like that so you know every
now and then your man just comes in you
know you you come back you know roast
but like no not in that obviously the
most cheesy ones like you know little
you know candlelight dinner you know
your man prepares the food he's waiting
for you a bouquet of flowers that just
shows you that he cares
but he's got to be the same with the
woman like sometimes the man comes back
at work and so that but that's what
that's what most people take for granted
because like
you you keep you do that but then
there's only only so much you can do so
it is very hard to keep it spontaneous
but i feel like you should still try to
do your best to keep your relationship
like keep your partner on your toes and
the post in a positive way sorry oh
that's kind of cute i'm
and saying you sir
[Laughter]
so
unauthentic on authentic women
it doesn't matter it doesn't it doesn't
it doesn't matter because we're all the
same
woman
[Laughter]
i'm in a different place too to you guys
um
i mean you're singles though
no yeah what up
i mean yeah
i'm sorry you shut up i have to get back
that's fine that's that's cool um
the
key thing for me before i date anybody
is that
um she has she doesn't have any children
and doesn't want her children that's the
first thing i look for you don't want
kids no no really
i mean fair enough your decision
so if once we get past that then we have
conversations but if you have i don't
date you if you want i don't know can i
ask why though
i feel like sharing this podcast a
different podcast
why you're leaving us hanging here you
hate kids like do you just don't like
them [ __ ] them kids
[ __ ]
yeah exactly [ __ ] them kids like i don't
list like children i don't know i
actually don't understand i just don't
want to have my own okay well that's
fair enough
that's fair enough you know
and the lineage you know host
help us
i think that's human hubris asking for
lineage
yeah i mean you're completely right like
human humans aren't perfect why should
we bring more humans there you go but i
feel like i feel like nobody's gonna be
lonely like at 80 like nothing well i
didn't say that i didn't say i want to
live by myself forever i just didn't
want the children oh okay you're
chocolating something else from you have
you have you wait have you found like
easily girls that don't want kids is
that easy for you or no not particularly
i've really i feel like there is a
select few people there different age
groups it changes
yeah but do you think there's a large
group of women that do not want kids no
there isn't
i feel like i know a lot like a lot of
my friends don't want kids well again
different age groups
maybe different age groups i think it
depends on personality personality as
well
i'll have to agree with women because i
know a couple of females in my age group
right they say they don't want kids
right but i know from the females that
are older than me right um that i've
known that they said they didn't want
kids then but at some point they will do
nothing
it will take everything it will take
everything
to remember
as a woman you have a you have a
situation where you have to use it or
lose it
so we've even if you're even if you're
on choice but you might even if you're
unsure whether you want to as well i
might as well because if i don't there's
a practice i'll get to a point where i
can't even have a change of mind so you
use it or lose it i guess that's a fair
point
20 something you could say i told you
something i don't want any
35 he's like well you won't be able to
have any mm-hmm so you might want
something this is not yours anymore yeah
but i do know some people that generally
um
are maybe they're in a relationship
that's not with a man they don't really
have that intention to have a child or
they're quite i
i think his point is like when push
comes to shove
most girls once
time's running out they want kids and
we're talking about the again we're
talking about the extremes of society we
look at the majority the majority i
think the majority of women do want
children i would agree with you there we
go i just feel like
yeah i think it's kind of a little
pleasure i feel like how many children
how many kids you want oh yeah i know
that i was gonna ask the next one i feel
like i want four but realistically i'll
have two whoa
no i want i want
in this economy i'll have two but like i
grew up in a big family and it was
really great it's great
it's great
okay i'm not
[Music]
so it's like an island next to mauritius
okay okay just middle of nowhere but
like honestly
i do look like the people from this
island but no one knows this island so
okay but yeah but yes i come from a big
family and i have the greatest time like
playing with it it's so nice having a
friend i have i have friends like i have
nine friends i don't need anybody like i
have my family
yeah like nine i have nine siblings so
like so i'm saying so i'm saying like i
have nine like now i have nine people
that i can like go to and
i genuinely everyone's i genuinely like
everything yeah like i have six siblings
not as big but like still quite sick
it's quite a big family and i really
like growing up it's quite difficult
because you don't really have that like
once one time with your parents but like
now i've moved out
amazing
i argue it makes you a better person
because you realize early that it is not
about you
you know what and there it is
it is about me i'm an only child it is
about me no i feel like people who have
multiple siblings have so many more life
skills from the get-go
because we compete with each other for
our parents attention
yup we would do everything my whole
family is funny
that is that is a hundred percent yeah
and then that's why every kid until me
and my family makes six figures i ruined
it because everyone where were you in
the
like what are my odds of being the
oldest or the youngest yeah so number
five four before
i was kind of number two though because
i grew up with six i was the second one
the one that he gave up they gave up for
adoption and three they adopted three
teenagers but when i was growing up
there was six and i was the second and
being the oldest girl do you have an
older brother
no i have an older sister okay i really
enjoyed growing up between two boys i
think that's why i'm a little bit of a i
think i would have appreciated growing
up with an older brother but i have a
younger brother and we're really close
and i really enjoy that i really enjoy
having siblings i think it's like i
don't know like you said you don't like
you don't want kids but i do feel like
maybe you can appreciate children so you
can i don't just like children yeah like
i feel like yeah why don't you want to
have kids
this conversation is a conversation we
can have it here we have another one
about it because this is a conversation
is it is it that long it's in depth is
it is it i'll say what i'm saying you
ask me questions
like your life experience
do you guys have anywhere to be i don't
have anywhere to be like i'm good like
okay so let's just have work
okay so
a couple reasons why and in no
particular order um
so i want to be able to summary like
what i call semi-retire in the next
three to four years
what that means to me is that i have
enough passive income so that i don't
have to go to work so when my alarm goes
up in the morning i know my electric my
gas won't go off it's all paid for
mm-hmm
before my feet hits the ground
i know i don't have to work so when i go
to work i'm going to work to find more
holidays
more expensive cars
whatever it is so just like you know
fund your own life and just be
responsible for one person it's kind of
like the driving force behind that so
that's why that's one thing another
thing is i don't have the patience or
temperament for children i don't have
the patience to be like don't do that
don't do that don't touch that you know
what do you know what i i respect that
because some people happy having kids
and they don't they don't they shouldn't
be having kids if you don't want kids
don't have them because i know a lot of
people that
maybe you shouldn't have had that kid
i don't want children to change my life
the way it is i have a very nice
lifestyle i don't want to change
and if i have children that will change
the way i do things children can stop
you from buying
expensive things nice things because
they break things they're noisy i don't
like absolutely not particularly like
anointing environments
um i can get one
just because without saying i love
telling i love telling young kids what
to do no it's i'm sorry i think it'd be
so much fun to have a child i'm not
going to lie yeah i i feel like this is
going to take other people it's all just
you're kind of a selfish person a little
bit no because i don't know i don't want
to partner with children yeah well i
know but like everything i'm hearing is
like quite egotistically yeah
like i but i think people that don't
want kids are a little bit egotistical
usually but i do feel like i respect
someone for i respect it it's okay some
people like you
they shouldn't have kids if you don't
want kids like some people will have
this mindset and have kids anyway and
then just make the kids life miserable
because they can't live their life they
want i do find offense to the word kids
i'd prefer the word children to kids why
because kid is a baby goat
but it's also known as kids in like
modern language but like why why why be
offended for no reason
why why be kids
well okay
i find annoying that we use the word kid
for a child i can't even back you up on
this
like everyone knows that kids what kids
means like in common language like
everyone's familiar with that is but i
still i don't like i prefer to use it i
like the term children because they are
true
so basically you want to retire and you
don't really like no you definitely
point it to me
so so basically you want that children
not just like children okay okay but you
don't you don't want to deal with that i
don't want one i don't want
yeah so so basically you want to retire
and you
you don't really want to deal with kids
it's like long steps that's a short
story
well that wasn't as long as i
made it
because what normally happens is i start
talking about it and the questions come
my way and then there's more things i
could add to it but questions come away
that's why it becomes a discussion are
you interested okay so you're not
interested in like what your genetic
like pool would be like what no like
what your children could be like no you
don't care if you leave something behind
can i get a can i want a child or like
about something else like you don't care
about
leaving something of value behind what
what you call value what are you trying
what are you doing
let's say you found someone you're
really in love with and you think so
like okay this person is amazing i love
this person inside and out
and imagine like you you love yourself
and you love this person imagine what
would come out of like the combined
version of your both no i don't think
that no you don't think about that no
okay can i
can i put you in a scenario sorry sorry
sorry it's actually right now go ahead
no it's not a tech it's interesting um
so like right now right you you you
found a beautiful one to live with right
you you've lived up for x amount of
years right um
are you open to marriage yeah yeah
okay let's say you're married and stuff
like that right and then
by some god you know god forbid like she
gets pregnant she doesn't tell you but
keeps the baby that baby is now yours
are you going to be
are you going to take care of your son
or daughter as a man i understand i have
zero reproductive rights mm-hmm so it is
what it is
oh
okay that's a very ominous is that like
you know that's very honest
what do you mean by that like is that
like i'm gonna okay i don't like kids
but i'm gonna choose to take an active
role in this child's life or i don't
care about kids i'll pay child support
but i choose not to be a parent
so that's a good question so i don't
honest honest answers i don't know
because because if i married someone she
understood where i was with children in
the beginning
so therefore we're in the same page so
why should keeping a child if i
accidentally i mean because abortion is
a traumatic process like some people
just can't i don't think mentally it's
not a mentally easy process for anybody
we understood but we got married right
yeah we we're not just dating we got
married so you see we knew where we
stood before we got married yeah but
let's say she gets pregnant and she's
too far along to even have an abortion
what do you do then so like i said i
don't know we'll see what happens at
that time i don't know how to be i don't
know how to i don't know what i'll do at
that point i think it's not an easy
question to ask i will i will
what i'll say to you is that i would i
would i know i'd be angry because if i'm
especially if i'm marrying you not no
you were married right you knew where i
stood in this situation i i married you
on the fact that you felt the same way
on that situation do you think you would
get now you changed the game midway
through would you get a vasectomy
because you're you don't want children
you're certain about that something i'm
considering yes i think if you get a
vasectomy then you kind of snip snip i
want some children
okay
that right now you know that [ __ ] to me
i don't know i've i've
spoke to a lot of friends about the
second thing like and that's and that
[ __ ] to me is like obviously it's uh
it's a simple procedure so it's
something that doctors do you know they
on a daily but for me that i just
i don't think i would but i do think
if you don't want kids like definitely
invest in getting a sort of con
contraception that works for you and
that's long term
like i feel like i've invested in like a
long time competition that works for me
and i feel like if you don't want kids
it's important to have that because i
mean that's the safest type of sex you
can get like a vasectomy you can if you
don't want kids and you're i mean you're
positive about that then you know do
your thing you know go to the doctor
find out what you can do i respect
someone in the comments red pill [ __ ]
donated and he said what is your purpose
without biological legacy what's my
purpose
i believe in purpose life is to create
memories
when you when i'm older you just
mentioned about me in age or something i
want to look back and say remember that
time when mm-hmm
all these stories is just like it's just
you though like i feel like you you're
you're you're misinterpreting what i
said just because i have don't want
george let me know i don't have a
long-term partner do you think it's not
mutually yeah
to have good memories and good times
we all have an abundance of single
childless women over 35 so just
in this economy yeah just just wait it
out they're coming back
okay um guys this is a really great show
i appreciate you coming in
this is like one of my favorite shows um
why don't you we go around um say any
final thoughts on where the people can
find you
um i think yeah i really enjoyed the
show today i feel like everyone was
quite authentic
original
yeah but like i i respect it like i
respect that we have different opinions
and we can talk about them and there's
not hard feelings i i really respect
that and i really enjoy listening to
other people's opinions and changing my
own opinions in the process and you can
find me at tiana pirates stanley on
instagram if you want to and they're all
tagged in my story on instagram so go to
my instagram just up pearly things can
follow me too yeah no i enjoyed i
enjoyed the show this is my third one i
believe um but yeah i'll say this is one
of my favorite ones as well because it
was it's a lot nicer when there's more
people with more opinions
but like just more people with different
opinions yeah everyone's different
everyone's authentic
and stuff but like you know everyone's
you know genuine yeah
you know just
what i'm saying um but yeah i i did
already enjoy the show thank you for
having me
um and you can find me on davida's
underscore goal of chunker
so i've had a great time um i'll come
again if i'm invited and if oh i can
also find parking around here
it's a real
problem um
you can find me on 1833 h t w e and
double free i did the rum reviews so i
bought some rum today me and w
it was you know what i'll show it if
that's right you can yeah yeah
we're not sponsored
but that's the ramp it's very nice
sippy cup sippy cup i'm not reviewing
this wrong i'll probably
i should normally i don't review rums
i've opened but i'll review the table um
probably the a few days why is it not
okay it is a new it's a it's this is
it's a dark room yeah
we can go for it but basically rum is
dark one specifically is made from
molasses it's perfect sugar
can i take a sip of this
[Music]
or the devil's juice
as it's known as it's known before 63
percent progress i am i am no stranger
to the darkroom of doctrine's probably
my one of my favorites i would i'd say
hands-down like a women
i like listen i like my listen i know
the way i describe my don't understand i
always described it like this right
when a person asked me like what's
happening
no no of course no no i'll tell you how
it is when a person every time a person
asked me right how do you like what type
of woman do you like do you like you
know
black or
asian whatever i was like listen i like
my chicken with a bit of seasoning on
let me see that way okay yeah
always liked it with a bit of seasoning
okay and i'm saying grilled and all that
stuff so yeah
that's a bit of me
[Music]
so we were
okay okay um oh [ __ ] okay it's really
good yeah yeah but you guys should go
subscribe to his channel he does rum
reviews that i haven't seen but i'll
probably
i'll probably even be on his next show
the last review was
i got back from mexico last week oh
sorry the last reboot was that was me
how was that
i'll add i'll add it to the description
if you send me the link mexico was lit
the what mexico was good where did you
go to mexico i was in pdc play the
common
are you going to go to nicaragua or like
tijuana
these are all the places
memories
yeah
listen what's happening to your honor
stay in tijuana i'm not gonna get into
it okay okay
maybe yeah after the show
okay um thanks for having me it's been a
pleasure yeah thanks for coming oh yeah
thank you for having me you guys have
all actually been great to have on i
thought this was a really good one
um okay guys don't forget to subscribe
to the channel as you guys know if
you've watched two or more of these
lives and you don't subscribe we have
beef
it's not it's not cool
i'm putting all this content out for you
guys okay um do that don't forget the
sponsor is cooking with chris they make
you completely customized meal plans
based on foods you already eat and like
guys i'm down like 12 okay i'm down 10 i
gave it
you gained irish i ate look at it look
at it i ate i ate some pizza this week
okay